with a oh hello everybody this is a true
podcast a beautiful Wednesday day joined
by the incredible highly requested oh
there we go Stavros helkius they say
your last name right you nailed it
yeah
[Laughter]
that's what I like to hear
that's what I like to hear
let's [ __ ] go baby actually you got a
ton of fans here in the studio I love it
uh good group I've been trying you know
your friend actually we have a lot of
overlap in our life yeah yeah I was just
on Hassan's stream yeah he's claiming to
be a plus-sized man despicable liar
piece of [ __ ] yeah he's a liar yeah yeah
he told me technically he's overweight
get the [ __ ] shut up [ __ ] shut the hell
up you Turkish piece of [ __ ] yeah
yeah the Greeks and the Turks is there
so yeah we've got a blood Feud yeah
blood Feud I'm still kind of trying to
Trojan Horse him I'm trying to get all
the I'm trying to get the codes I'm
trying to get the codes to his mansion
and then yeah yeah [ __ ] he lets me in
I'm taking all his like protein candies
I'm taking all this
I was [ __ ] [ __ ] uh today's episode is
sponsored by Adam and Eve gamer subs
expressvpn and PayPal honey who we all
love so well thank you great thank you
PayPal buy dildos use a VPN for whatever
weird porn you're downloading you got it
all yes
three in one shot yeah yeah yeah
actually we're gonna forget one well so
Adam and Eve we call it our favorite
e-commerce website because we're not
allowed to sell the dodos these but we
got we got a loophole because you can
sell dildos on Amazon interesting right
okay Amazon they straight up buy ads on
YouTube that's true and so I was like
well it's an e-commerce website or Adam
and Eve they're also they just do
e-commerce they do e-commerce you know
what other [ __ ] they got on there they
got anything you can't [ __ ] probably is
there one item there that you can't [ __ ]
something pull up something that you
can't [ __ ] man we'll prove it right now
let's figure it out it's my favorite
e-commerce website I love e-commerce
cardboard export yeah
yeah by the way congratulations on your
oh so they sell laundry there we go you
can [ __ ] in it though
right is there anything not [ __ ]
anything that's true you're a
beekeeper's outfit you can cut a hole in
and get your dick sucked you're right
find me something non-sexual on that
e-commerce website looks like they have
a bath and body section oh there we go
there we go my favorite Bath and Body uh
yeah yeah aromatherapy massage oil ah
there you go yeah I know what that's
really for yeah yeah yeah okay get you
loose they sell is that poppers is that
with the aromatherapy oil is poppers
you're not familiar with poppers is that
where you where you the VHS cleaner that
loosens up your [ __ ]
you don't know about this wait that's
the the CO2 [ __ ] I don't I don't know
it's official scientific name I just
have a lot of gay friends and they love
right why is that I know I you know how
I said it loosens up your [ __ ] yeah I
think that's probably what it is it's
just loses
because I've heard I've had friends who
do it and I'm like I'm not doing that
and I've done [ __ ] up drugs right I've
done it all but I've seen my friends sit
there doing poppers was like no I think
I the one time I did poppers it was my
30th birthday I had just seen uh into
the spider-verse on four tabs of acid
really and I was kind of coming down we
had a nice little party at a beer hall
and just one of my friends had poppers I
was like why not so I don't really
remember exactly so loosen up I couldn't
tell you I did I don't I was still on
acid and kind of coming down but
somebody researched why
um poppers is a is is used in gay sex in
my ears that's correct I'm packing that
yeah okay all right yeah oh they say
it's a muscle relaxant so there you go
you're telling it on there I'm telling
you
thank you yeah okay I know my stuff this
is an educational podcast
let's tell these [ __ ] about
Papa and and can you buy and did you
guys find anything safe for work I mean
we got Aroma there we got the oil it's
fine yeah shaving cream shaving cream
you know be funny we should have them do
a copy for us about like a bathroom
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah
just like a shampoo never mind that it's
called decomer it's like it's like it's
meant to get [ __ ] out of your hair right
and that's still a share our product
yeah yeah and when you got it in there
you got it although if you were to go
with uh There's Something About Mary
so maybe it's just a can of come maybe
yeah
where's that Source from
can I buy some ads Bob's hair gel is
just me beating off into a mason jar
yeah so also I want to say that uh stov
uh Stavros stop whatever you want
uh you're on tour
in February you're going all around the
country is that right yeah we got the
first leg of the tour it's selling
really well I'm kind of shocked to thank
everybody for buying tickets uh the fat
Rascal dude it's like these big theaters
and we're adding shows how many seats
you doing uh thousand seater let's
[ __ ] go it'll be great yeah yeah so
in some of them we're really selling out
but I'm going all over the place so
here's Stavros at uh stavi stavy baby
and you how'd you get that Biz done dude
it was tough
bro yeah so you guys can come here get
some tickets yeah scroll down look at
that [ __ ] they're going fast
[ __ ] oh yeah oh the way go
ahead I forgot I've also bro I brought
you guys cookies I also brought
calendars because I sell a calendar
every year I sell Narada calendar uh I
want that of course how could I forget I
got you bro oh I got more Intel in the
poppers if we want to go back to that
because yeah because poppers increase
blood flow and can relax the walls of
the anus and vagina okay is that say
does that say and vagina or are you just
thinking no no it's there okay I never
been with the girl who needed her vagina
[Laughter]
fights more popular in the gay community
than the straight Community it's a dink
it's a dick shrinker and a [ __ ]
loosener
some people take it while they're having
sex there you go my friend if you're
curious for more info yeah I am so so by
the way yeah Markiplier is no yeah so
he's a [ __ ] he did this too and he's
a [ __ ] coward only fans promising the
show dick anymore you didn't show dick
no he is if I promised I haven't shown
dick yet but I'm keeping a little
something you can't you get something
for my wife
look at that you can buy these on the
website on the website slavi.biz yeah
these are nice I would be careful that's
my ass
[Laughter]
three or post bumpers it's free you can
tell how high and tight it is yeah it
looks nice thanks man every girl's
fantasy the pool boy that's right
yeah and also I want to congratulate you
on the success of your uh special oh
thanks dude pretty incredible for uh
comedian to upload their special and for
it to do so well yeah no I was shocked
four million it's at four million we're
four million views yeah it was like I
just it's a the best thing that I ever
did for my career was just make a really
expensive YouTube video basically and it
was like no one wanted to buy it
um not you know Netflix nothing maybe
you know there's a couple weird
streamers
that it's like I'm not you know like
what this isn't going up on like I'm not
putting my [ __ ] up on 2B yeah you know
what I mean like I'm not I'm not doing
that [ __ ] or some other like
subscription that might not even be
around anymore but I was just like I
just want people to see it and so I put
a lot of money into it and then it
[ __ ] it did it did crazy so yeah it
was shot really beautifully you know
well well conceived well shot I mean
it's super professional it's exactly
what you'd see on a on a big streaming
platform yeah we got really lucky uh
shout out to Dylan Sanford he dpd he he
does like every he does like Netflix
stuff I think he literally I was looking
at his IMDb uh and he literally worked
on like the Super Bowl halftime show
like this guy he's incredible and we got
lucky because we shot it in LA and I did
it on a Monday and it was like these
guys live here they're not doing [ __ ] so
you can kind of get him on a deal you
know but I had to do I had to shoot my
special at 6 p.m on a Monday okay and
then one at eight and the six was a
little people are just coming off work
they're still masks there's just like
you know last December so it was a
little little touchy but then you know
we really got it on the second one but
it was great man yeah so you guys did
two shows and then spliced the Great
Moments together exactly yeah yeah yeah
and I like to [ __ ] with the crowd so
there was like a nice little Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah from each one nice
yeah I recommend it super funny everyone
here loved it and they're tough crowds
man these guys are [ __ ] haters oh
yeah you should hear them talk about
other stand-ups yeah yeah [ __ ] talk just
me [ __ ] every other stand up I think we
can all agree yeah but so the success of
this you got 4.1 million people to come
watch an hour-long stand-up set
when you posted it did it go like
immediately viral or how was the yeah it
did pretty good up top I mean I
um I didn't have much going on on my
YouTube before and so I started posting
like crowd work Clips because I I when I
was working on the special I filmed
every hour that I did for like six
months because I wanted to like fine
tune things I was you know I was taking
it very seriously and there was just
these moments that weren't you know
weren't in the act that I was just
[ __ ] with people and I was like well
I don't want to use my material so why
don't I just put these up just kind of
on a lark and be like I'll build up a
little YouTube presence and those just
kind of went [ __ ] crazy which I
wasn't expecting that's so cool and so I
I had like 20 000 subscribers when it
started and before the before the
um special I think I had like I got up
to like 250k just off the just off the
shore almost at 600 000 yeah yeah now
and now and then there's a huge bump
from the special and then I just kept
doing the shorts and stuff and so yeah
yeah the views on these are great
they're doing good and I just started
another podcast stavy's world stavy's
world yeah which is on uh YouTube Right
on YouTube baby you know I'm trying to
get like you I need a compound I want to
I want but days in my studio toilet yeah
you're right you know but I don't like
the communal bidet I feel like other
people's [ __ ] is getting squirted in my
ass oh that's a good point I never
thought of it
I think I'm the only one I told them it
takes the luxury out of the bidet it
does yeah you know like I'll do I have a
bidet at home but it's my I'm the only
ass getting squirted well not even your
family it's a monogamous relief oh dude
wow I didn't know you were so uptight
I'm Polly when it comes to when it comes
to the days yeah I'll [ __ ] get
anybody's [ __ ] water up my ass I don't
care
I'm open yeah I love that about you but
we have a communal one right that
everyone [ __ ] with and so my bidet
actually has a drying function love that
okay that's the next level so the one of
my bedroom is just for me wow and when I
dry I know that's just the smell of my
own fecal matter blowing in my face but
when I'm downstairs yeah at the communal
one and sometimes you hit that dryer
button and it's don't smell right I
gotcha yeah and I'm and I'm just I don't
like that at all it scares me but I
still use it I think you need to open up
your horizons in Japan they got them in
public toilets but they dry your ass
they dry your ass too oh wow I got it
all bro I think if you do a good enough
job on the squirt yeah the dry you need
to teach whoever's [ __ ] in your
communal bathroom to fully wash their
ass with the bidet that's your issue if
a bidet is used correctly I don't think
you should be smelling anything there's
no [ __ ] on the dryer yeah so I kind of
had to strategize a little bit because
sometimes when I [ __ ] I know this maybe
sound crazy but I didn't even think
about it I would blow dry my ass while
this [ __ ] was in no that's you you're
thinking you got hot [ __ ]
stands for my [ __ ] coming up and so I
realized oh okay why no no wait wait no
no sorry it was that I was I would yeah
I would flush my [ __ ] okay and then
squirt my ass and so there was a little
bit of [ __ ] not a full dump okay okay
that'd be crazy to be to be drying with
a full [ __ ] you're basically you're just
wafting [ __ ] hair into your nose it was
a light wow I think you need two flushes
before the dryer even you even start
thinking about the dress that's what I
do now okay yeah that's right yeah all
right you should be fine then yeah yeah
I'm doing it so yeah yeah thank you by
the time I get up a day I'm gonna I'm
gonna [ __ ] know it you know I've
learned from I'll learn from your
mistakes well there's actually other
interesting moves you can do with the
the bidet as I've gotten more experience
with it I'm listening you can if you
have a nice fine jet or sometimes it
just goes like a fire hose like in the
bathroom it's intense but yeah yeah you
can shoot it up your ass fully up your
ass and like if you're constipated you
could literally give yourself an enema I
don't know about that one
[Laughter]
I don't know about that so A few few
times you know there's been some
constipation and I go
let's get an animal some water on my ass
all right but get a real enema not a
bidet animal yeah oh see Abel so thank
you for backing me up so you squirt
water up your at your house when I had
the spicy chip it was hard to come out
so I needed some assistance from you you
are constipated yeah I was like yeah and
it was hot very hot
whoa you know about the spicy chip
challenge I have heard about it yeah
have you done it and I haven't you want
to do it but not really not particular
after what he said about his ass how he
just he's constipated with a ball of
fire up his ass I think I'm good how'd
you get constipated with that because
when I eat spicy it just I no I don't
know it took forever I wasn't feeling
anything yeah later in the night and to
remedy this you put water up your ass is
what you're saying okay all right well I
stand correct and it worked right but
wait but they water up your ass but day
water yeah all right well yeah helpful
looking things up man okay I'm in there
I'll give it a shot yeah there's all
kinds of applications to the bidet
sometimes I drink out of it this is the
water bottle the squirt bottle
of course if it's fresh yeah maybe right
before I maybe right before I installed
the day I'll just drink from it to say I
did yes before anyone shits in it right
who gives I mean still toilet water but
whatever that's fine yeah yeah by the
way so uh anyway guys check out uh
Stavros helkius YouTube channels all
happening that's right still happening
so congrats on all that thank you bro I
appreciate it thank you thank you so
much yeah all right cool well thanks
yeah I'm gonna take off so
yeah what are your thoughts on Helen
Keller
um
I guess I'm
I'm lightly she's a very interesting
person because you got a lot of
different layers right apparent blind
all that kind of [ __ ] blind mute all
that kind you know classic what we know
about Helen Keller uh so it's kind of
deaf too right deafblind the whole thing
right so a did she really learn how to
do anything I find that hard to believe
right but let's say she did right let's
go with the story then you also hear
that she's racist as hell that's another
one so it's like that kind of you know
it's like [ __ ] you can't see in your
race how do you know to be racist you
can't hear it's all smell is that what
it is
a black man yeah she knows black
pheromones and she doesn't like them
yeah so those are the two competing ones
and then also I think she might have
been a communist or something I don't
remember Eugenics she's a Eugenics
person she figured that [ __ ] out wait a
second she's gonna she's gonna Eugenics
herself yeah she wanted to kill herself
she's like the [ __ ] that was
working with the aliens to get
to get the Earth blown up right you know
what I mean like how are you gonna be a
Eugenics guy she's a traitor to all the
deafblinds absolutely she would have
gotten punted in Sparta so fast they
would have [ __ ] kicked their ass into
the lake and she was like thank you I
deserved it yes I guess you know what
now that we're talking about it [ __ ]
Helen Keller I don't [ __ ] okay thank you
I'm on a mission to expose this [ __ ] I
get a rest and she's a fraud you're
telling me she's like oh I can't see I
can't hear I can't oh [ __ ] you right
right I agree with that I don't trust
her there's no [ __ ] so you think she
can see at least she could at least see
or hear frankly I don't even know that
she existed at all okay interesting the
whole thing's in question for me yeah I
mean I guess if she did it was really
impressive whoever taught her how to do
anything deserves a little shout out you
know that you know those guys when you
go on vacation they come up to the table
and they're like they hand you a little
pamphlet they're like hi I can't speak
right that's what she that's her whole
[ __ ] line she had pamphlets
check this merch out we found unrelated
merch Owen Keller merch Helen Keller
denier
by the way I love how they put this on
like model like right yeah right right
just just a cute they had no idea that
there was not at all there ain't no way
I think there might be a way but I don't
[ __ ] with her personally and what we
just discussed she did come across some
adversity but to become a Eugenics
person and be racist off smell and I
guess maybe taste
like baseball
I'm like that right here let me find
yeah I went to our Wikipedia page
there's not a controversy section for
Helen Keller [ __ ] dude sanitized
let's get that going let's get that
going guys do a little research look she
apparently has a signature look at this
[ __ ]
there ain't no [ __ ] way well
it does look like [ __ ]
so maybe it is that K doesn't even
connect I thought it was [ __ ] that that
case sucks look at that that case
embarrassing yeah that's pretty bad what
if she look can we can we just look at
it for a second you idiot oh yeah what
do you okay I'm not I got to tone it
down you know I bet you know I wouldn't
what is Young Helen Keller look like you
know if she's [ __ ] up I want to see if
she could yeah if she was [ __ ] and
what would that experience even be like
I'm getting hot yeah yeah
let's see
let's rank Helen Keller yeah
oh yeah okay what do you think I'm kind
of into that one honestly yeah but you
know the problem is that's her best
angle as a as a fat man I know that you
take the right angle you can look okay
here you go now I'm out [ __ ] that we're
not doing it for you I'm back out on her
okay she's a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah she's a [ __ ] oh she has smell oh
there we go why are you flexing on me
yeah
like I get it you can smell big deal
when did this Helen Keller thing start
what about it what set you off on this
anti-hellon Keller crusade to me it's
just like uh
there's just no way you know like I'm
meant to believe that all that like you
know we're doubting so many fundamental
truths about Society right all these
conspiracy theories like uh let's say
you know they say that Donald Trump's
still the President right a storm is
coming by the way they say yes
cue any moment now
you know they say the World is Flat yeah
yeah I'm saying y'all talking about you
got your ish sign on the wrong [ __ ]
right you're talking about a woman who
was blind deaf and mute writing books
about Eugenics yeah hell no ain't no way
are there any other Helen Kell like
she's the most famous one who are the
other blind deaf mute [ __ ]
who's the second most famous blind deaf
mutant I think she's the only one
because usually they just end up in like
a [ __ ] black hole of nothingness
well these guys just maybe eating
there's no reason they couldn't be like
chefs that would be kind of interesting
like it's not really a chef like
Ratatouille yeah right you get one of
those [ __ ] with a Ratatouille
now we're talking
about Burrows in her
brainer
oh wait what if what if Helen Keller was
a Ratatouille situation what if a really
racist mouse got into her hat and made
her type all those eugenic stories
[Laughter]
dude fled from Germany once [ __ ] went
started going bad yeah you know he left
Hitler's bunker that's one once he shot
himself that's more plausible frankly
than the explanation we have today her
father worked for many years as an
editor uh for the two scumbia North
Alabama
okay okay he had served as a captain of
the Confederate Army wow Trader whoa
wait here she's from here yeah her dad
was a captain in the Confederate Army
race so racist from the jump yes yes
gotcha the flammer were part of the
slave holding Elite before the war wow
but lost status later see that explains
yeah [ __ ] Helen Keller honestly she's
not chill though her mother was the
daughter of Charles W Adams a
confederate general oh my God yeah how
about this okay ready this is what I'm
getting on my ancient Greek [ __ ] what if
there were such horrible slave owners
that they like blinded a slave took a
slave's like tongue out and then also
[ __ ] one of their ears up and God was
like
now now your [ __ ] daughter doesn't
get any of that [ __ ] yeah what if issues
it's a possibility it's we don't know
that they didn't [ __ ] with slaves The
Killers weren't bad slave owners it's CL
well there were many good ones
you got me there
no you're right you're right I'm gonna
I'm gonna take one I'm gonna redact good
slave owner let me I wanted a good one
you know what I mean I let him take a
break
yeah yeah of course I won't be paying
them or treating them as humans hell no
no
so you're right maybe this is uh it's
clearly it is clear from God punishment
for previous uh sins yeah yeah this is
how that works we're mixing a little
Buddhism in there she [ __ ] over every
God yeah that's true there it is you're
gonna stop dissing the Nazis all the
time
well tell that to Helen Keller oh wait
she can't hear and she's dead yeah she's
dead too actually so I that I would yeah
anyway if you know about the second best
def you guys get any intel not do we
have enough blind we need a new role
model for this yeah Olivia sent a list I
gotta be honest it's not impressive a
bunch of Duds well Julia brace you guys
familiar with Julia brace blind deaf
blindness oh okay so it's both deaf
blind is that what Helen Keller had yeah
okay so she can't see
or any of them not racist search that
non-racist death they all seem to be
from the 1800s so frankly no very
unlikely
all right yeah let's see let's see the
modern day deafblind oh they stop they
just stop happening Danny Del cambre
this is the most recent one 1959 it's
not that Helen Keller was successful
they're Eugenics some people were
reading those papers yeah we just well
that's okay we just outside okay now I'm
starting to you know what now I'm with
you because if it stops suddenly in 1959
it was never really happening you know
and before that it's like we're eating
plastic we're doing all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] there should be more it's extra
blindness than ever well maybe that's
really what it was how bad medicine was
that maybe a doctor's just really [ __ ]
up a blind kid's ears or something oh
they're like this is back in the day
kids eyes they're like okay your baby
can't see what we're gonna do is take a
ice pick and Hammer it to do it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're gonna put
we're gonna put uh Taiwanese man's blood
into his eyes we're gonna inject it that
should do it the pubes of a Taiwanese
man yeah ground up yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah injected and we're gonna we're
gonna have a leech eat it and suck
exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah medicine was wild back the
leeching for sure
so yeah that's probably what it was
you're right it's fake yeah
and she's a racist she [ __ ] her family
yeah [ __ ] the Killers and they're all a
bunch of Confederate scum that's right
all right let's move on
[ __ ] Helen Keller
wait wait wait what's next on the docket
so we saw this picture and this might
explain things so maybe this maybe it's
not Helen Keller's fault after all oh
there it is I knew it got a mouth she's
got a mouse it's a racist he's doing a
Sig Heil yes the mouse it's the mouse
got an armband
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
is that what's going on with Kanye is
there a racist Mouse under that under
that mask
let me go
and his voice got weird too maybe the
mouse was directly talking because she's
a little more high-pitched right anyway
something to consider it's just there's
I really want to keep listening to
College Dropout so if if a mouse did it
that would really that would really that
would really bail me out trouble
listening to Kanye or you just let it
slide before you even have to answer
that sure because I know it's a tricky
question yeah Zach who is Jewish okay
still rocks Kanye I I think he's on is
that right you still play it just own it
um
I'm Jews for Jesus man yeah
that's over bro so there you go I was a
die-hard I stuck with him through a lot
a lot of stuff but it was really it was
really explicitly being like Hitler
rocks the guy that I was like all right
I'm off I'm off this train like that was
the one
I got ice miles no worries dude now what
he really went so far his last stalwart
uh allies were like on Kanye
subreddit and there's these guys that
had a Kanye podcast and they all bailed
at a certain point they turned the Kanye
subreddit into a Taylor Swift
that also breaks my heart and then they
turned it into a um Holocaust Memorial I
saw that yeah yeah that was pretty good
that was pretty good but yeah it broke
my heart I mean once the
I mean yeah I don't know so I just hope
I'm crossing my fingers it's a [ __ ]
Nazi Mouse if it's a mouse then then
yeah then we're good then we're all so
okay Cameron we have to kill the mouse
that's what I was saying what are we
gonna do about the mouse the mouse yeah
you got to do something about it you
gotta do something about these nasty
mouses you know it's just the beginning
of Newark and how many other what if no
one's what if no one's racist or a Nazi
what if it's these Ratatouille racist
mice yeah yeah yeah rata jewies
right the Jews are controlling the media
yo I don't think Harvey Weinstein they
didn't rape anyone it was the mouse
oh maybe they're alien mouses his little
[ __ ] up dick that was the mouse's dick
he pulled his little mouse dick through
the [ __ ] pants that's one of my
favorite details about Harvey and not
you know yeah right favorite the way
there's good slave owners there's
favorite Harvey wants to see details but
his dick was apparently like rotten
mangled yeah apparently his balls were
inserted in his thigh wow the man had
thigh balls that's crazy like what a
little pocket like a kangaroo he had a
house for his nuts yup he had some kind
of um like fungal thing that ate his
which is hot that's another one okay
yeah that is that sexy that is sick
infection and stuff now we're really
getting back to like karma [ __ ] which
like if you're a rapist your balls
literally rotting off it's pretty it's
pretty much what you deserve God is
trying to make a point he's making a
point with Harvey so let's see one of uh
Harvey's victims described his penis as
disgusting
sure well I've had mine described as
such yeah yeah
and thank you oh you got a bad penis
it's fine actually we're just regular
you would say
my the thing about my dick my
relationship with my dick is it's
changed over the years where like I used
to be skinny and athletic and at that
point in my life I was proud of my your
dick was primed ready to go at all times
then as I started to gain weight you see
it less you see it yep loses less blood
to uh of course and then all of a sudden
it's not that impressive yeah yeah it's
sadder it's not very girthy
no problem what about your dick my dick
is pretty sting I've got a [ __ ] up
penis for sure but what about it it's
I've got a tight foreskin so it doesn't
go back all the way oh it's kind of like
the what I like to say is like imagine
trying to get a fat toddler and a baby's
turtleneck you know you're trying to
pull it down and it won't go back all
the way and so are you Pro uh
circumcision I am strongly anti because
that would have helped us but I'm just I
would consider myself a traitor if I got
my my foreskin snipped off yeah but
sometimes there's a medical need nah
dude never never not for this okay save
some tight I'm a pro I'm Pro I'm Pro
foreskin no matter what no matter I'm a
foreskin absolutely yeah yeah yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I like
that so I'm keeping mine even though it
you have to have a real finesse approach
to work with my penis really so it's
that hard to get that thing back yeah
does that hurt you yank it too much oh
yeah yeah so again doesn't stretch out
over time you think it's loosen a little
bit but not as much as you you'd want it
to so when you were younger it was even
worse even worse I I'm trying to figure
out like the way like Hot Topic guys put
those gauges in their ears I feel like I
could do that to my penis but I just
don't have the gauge you know I want a
heavy duty one so if anyone here is like
you you know adamandeve.com they have
coffee ages I mean amongst other great
e-commerce but at goods and services
yeah yeah anyway if you if you're a fan
of Hoobastank they used to manage a uh
uh [ __ ] let's not put dick in
Hoobastank you don't think so it doesn't
feel right I was because you know is
that even right though does Hoobastank
fans have those earrings who am I
thinking of what kind of bands okay it
feels like a Hoobastank feels Hoobastank
yeah that feels right this is
interesting now we if we examine
if we examine this a little bit oh no
okay now hold on hold on holy [ __ ] so
this is Kanye West right oh no it is and
that's a mouse and it's wearing a glance
it's like a clown top a clan top
klansman got on Kanye West that's a
shame
that's a real issue well let's spin
[ __ ] late registration
it's all good we're sad to go on a mouse
genocide right now we really do because
they're dangerous these ratatouilles
yeah Julius
rat a death toll Jews not cool not cool
so let's get that mouse off him yeah so
um yeah my penis is fine I'm circumcised
so I don't I have I see I it never had a
problem I don't have an issue with it
your lifestyle your choice you know
thank you I can co-exist we can coexist
well my yeah
yeah you know I circumcise my kids
because we're Jewish right and my wife
uh she you know she's a strong issue
we're not religious or anything but to
be honest I I'm happy my dick
circumcised I don't have a problem there
that's your that's um uh internalized
anti-for-skin phobia it could be it is
you know it's like you've been mangled
at Birth and you're making the best of
it it could but not me it could be I'm
not me even through pain I keep my
natural penis
just kind of the kind of guy how do you
know it's not better over here bro your
[ __ ] is I don't need my [ __ ] there's a
[ __ ] there's a rat just strangling
your [ __ ] at every minute no dude
there's just something to I could never
look I couldn't go back to Greece and
look my cousin in the eye knowing my
dick is different than his I don't know
I don't want to [ __ ] up your love don't
[ __ ] up my family life I'm gonna come
get you when you're sleeping one night
like operation
they need a circumcision version of
operation where you don't wake the guy
up but you circumcise him I don't think
that's possible
um all right well there we go uh it's
been uh 30 minutes we're gonna do an ad
break but uh actually have a lot we
barely touched this we got showing to
Helen oh I wanted to say [ __ ] don't
get me back
that's on me [ __ ] her keep it moving a
liar dude
someone needs to hold her accountable
absolutely uh let's desecrate her to
himself
put the whole Tombstone up our ass
yeah I'm not doing that just for the
record all right
um I'm still undecided so we have a
comedian who's a friend of the show he's
an up-and-comer and I use that in the
most
generous terms sure he's shitty at
comedy is that what you're saying
in some circles
yeah and your words not mine I don't
I don't know his name's Jimmy Lee okay
he's his the moniker is the Jersey
Outlaw moniker is already a big problem
you do not need a moniker to do things
he's the Jersey Outlaw okay he's got a
whole Persona okay I mean no chance he's
good so he's gonna call in at 2 30. okay
and I was hoping that you as a
professional Community could give him
feedback sure he has a set prepared for
us he's going to do a set over the phone
yeah he on Zoom we'll see a video okay
great and so you know and he's like I
said he's a friend of the show he knows
everything we do so you don't have to
feel bad I won't break I will not give
him the whole the whole I won't pull my
punches for the Jersey Outlaw good man
so that's exciting so you can bring some
of that old-timey humor uh 2 30. uh so
let's say a throw to a break I pre-re
recorded because I knew that we were
probably gonna get my sponsors canceled
yeah yeah yeah I pre-reported it to keep
it clean so we're gonna roll to that
good and uh when we come back more with
Stavros helkius you got it
guys thank you to my favorite e-commerce
website
Adam and Eve
they are basically my favorite
uh website that does e-commerce
and they sell all kinds of range of
products
um some cylinder shaped
right
some would say phallic shaped but not a
phallic
but just in that shape can I say phallic
yeah I don't think so I think that's
just that that describes the shape they
sell like they sell like um
so they sell materials that makes things
slick right
right one might call them uh lubricants
lubricants right because the you can
there's all kinds of lubricants there's
like
car lubricants
there's even boat lubricants yeah and
I've used some of that to to lube up my
treadmill because I needed some hardcore
[ __ ] that lasted so they I don't think
they sell Boat Boat lubricants to be
totally clear
yeah no they do they do yeah they do
have and actually they sell they have
the best cylinder cylinder shapes the
best lubricants and they even have
receptacles hmm like if you you know
when you plug a light into a socket yeah
so the socket would be the receptacle
uh-huh yeah that's right yeah and so if
you want to put your plug into a socket
this would be also a good place to shop
for that and among other e-commerce
products actually it gets even better
guys if you go to
adamandeve.com my favorite e-commerce
website with the range of products you
can get over 50 percent off almost any
item plus free shipping that is insane
wow wow wow I know it's shocking amazing
I miss you use the code H3 at checkout
to get the offer that's 50 off almost
any item plus free shipping the link is
in the description
thank you to adamandeve.com my favorite
e-commerce website
Gamers up Nations I love my Gamers up it
means the world to me let me hit this
real fast
that's so refreshing it's energizing
it's it's doing so much for me and you
know what I really love about it
I don't have to drink sugary drinks to
get a good hit of energy and something
that tastes sweet and something that
tastes great and that's what gamer Subs
is all about
sub Nation
what's up Nation
that's almost like yeah
I can see Philly D saying like what's
what's up Nation Philly sup Nation
what's up
yeah I love it man this is the black
cherry the one that I personally just
can't get enough of but there's so many
flavors there's like pineapple pina
colada and uh guacamole farts and also
titty milk
was it's titty milk that's the name of
it
yeah but even against even against titty
milk flavor black cherry is my go-toed
here's what I love
use the code H3 you'll get 10 off your
whole order always
and if you don't believe us pay the five
dollars in shipping and get some free
samples so you can try and make that
decision for yourself so there you go
just pay for five dollar shipping you
can get a free sample try it for
yourself you're gonna love it you know
coffee it just hits me it hits me kind
of hard it's like acidic you gotta put
cream in it it's Gamers up for life
thank you gamer Subs
happy holidays it's the season of giving
but you've already given enough to your
service internet service provider if you
haven't been using expressvpn every time
you've gone online this year let's fix
that and I'm not talking about the
enormous internet bill you pay every
month every time you go online without
expressvpn your provider like at T and
Verizon can see every flipping thing
you're doing
heck no and yes that includes all the
sites you visit in incognito mode
on top of overcharging they're also
legally allowed to sell your browsing
activity the third party advertisers for
massive profits where's my muck out of
that that's why I'm done giving the
internet service providers I always go
online with expressvpn the app encrypts
and reroutes 100 of my network data
through the secure server so my provider
can't see a thing yo if they want to
sell my data I'm getting a cut that's my
day though if you all know what kind of
big titty uh expanding expressed anime
eye watch on Wednesday at 8pm I want to
cut of that [ __ ]
thank you
it couldn't be easier to simply fire up
expressvpn on any of your devices phone
laptop whatever tap one button to
connect and that's it unlike your
internet service provider expressvpn is
committed to your privacy the privacy
policy has been audited by third party
so you can rest assured that your data
is not being logged by anyone
if you're you've been given enough to
your ISP this year it's time for you to
start taking
so take back your internet privacy today
with the VPN rated number one by tech
radar and Mashable visit expressvpn.com
H3 and get three extra months for free
expressvpn that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com H3
expressvpn.com H3 to learn more
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey
is the easiest way to save when you're
shopping on your iPhone or computer
that's right it's the holidays and we're
all be shopping
we all be shopping thanks to honey you
don't have to manually search for coupon
codes to make sure you're getting the
best deal possible it's a free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one to find
Sierra cart if you're not using honey
you're not using your brain
because it's free it's easy and it's
guaranteed to save you a bunch of money
check out all these savings we got
good this is all savings earned by us by
passively having this extension open
you go to the checkout
honey goes hey do you want me to check
the internet for coupons yo yeah
obviously click the button
calculating boom huge discounted
checkout easy easy yeah
so good imagine you're at one of your
favorite sites and when you click the
checkout code
check out the honey button appears and
all you do is Click apply coupon boom
it's like magic
you know it's I'm talking like Furniture
food
Electronics
one thing that I really like is they can
track the price data
do it on Amazon the prices are
fluctuating like crazy I don't know if
it's like a supply shortage or
because I feel like sometimes they sell
out and then the third party guys jack
up the price like and so they'll they'll
track the the price of stuff on Amazon
for you so you know when you're getting
the lowest price for sure and you're not
overpaying by like 200 percent
yeah you don't you can save even more
when you ask honey to keep track of
price drops I just said that
if a price drops anything in your list
you'll instantly get an alert to let you
know if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself
assault and scoring the show thank you
we love honey I use honey I love honey
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com H3 that's joinhoney.com
H3 thank you thank you
yourself and that's what it is
absolutely wow look at that guy what a
great cell are you right on point I just
bought all that [ __ ] yeah me too 10 of
them how about 10 honeys or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah no the Honeys love honey I
love honey who was that who thought we
were promoting honey the oh that was
Howie Mandel
in front of him he's like what the [ __ ]
kind of out of this you're selling honey
I was like yes Howie Howie's not
familiar with the concept of brand names
he just thinks it's all Concepts he's
not good at branding Amazon what is the
we're going to the river we're going to
Brazil actually you want to know how
good Howie is at branding and he's a
friend of the show I love Howie we kid
how I could because we love him oh yeah
he's cool as [ __ ] I [ __ ] with Howie man
though yeah but I'll show you how good
of branding he is on his podcast which
nobody watches by the way don't his most
popular episode is with me by the way
I'm not even kidding I want to show you
this man did his whole podcast with it
backwards he's not his face facing away
he put glasses we're gonna know
it's an iconic look how he thinks his
glasses but uh him and Jeff Dunham I got
him to change it up so that's good I got
I finally broke through wow there it is
you know what I'm much and unfortunately
the views didn't he's got Scooter Braun
8K views with Scooter Braun God damn
nobody likes his ass
but does anyone like Scooter Brown I
mean who asked for that I guess that's
true but like you know Bill Maher
surprise people came from now we're
talking I guess he's a big name now
we're talking but yeah if you go to just
go to most popular at the top look at
that that's you [ __ ] def Jeff Jeff
Dunham suck my dick yeah yeah put those
puppets on my balls Jeff Dunham
if the puppet sucks your dick does he
have to do the sound you have his his
lips don't move but you don't get it
yeah
I
think he's
I don't know what's like comedian code
sure I don't know Jeff Dunham I don't
particularly hack [ __ ] yeah I haven't
really ever seen a single moment of Jeff
Dunham really so he has these puppets
and he they say he's like a apparently a
family comedian he's the most popular
comedian in America apparently because
60 of America is just like yeah no I
mean it makes sense to that like you
know dumb the thing I have seen is that
the like I guess I guess if I remember
correctly it was a racist puppet all of
them are super rich after 9 11 he won a
tour with Ahmed the undead terrorist
look at this
it's like it's so crazy and nobody talks
about what a [ __ ] that's wrong crazy
[ __ ] that's hysterical hey oh careful
out I'll kill you he's threatening
everybody I'm gonna blow up this
Auditorium it was like yeah is that a
Jew in the front room
and the other one is the spicy jalapeno
um
that's awesome so yeah his trademark is
silence I kill you oh air is down the
crowd that's awesome yeah when you pull
up the spices I love them I love the
necklace too the jet and the [ __ ]
rhinestones around the collar yeah now
that's a [ __ ] that's a that's a blue
collar man right there this is a man who
practices with a shield out um
[Laughter]
the show is too hard for me today it's
straight up so racist
hey get your bag Jeff yeah no he has get
your bag brother yes it's awesome I've
always been um weirdly fascinated by
that he's he's dressing like the that's
like a man who just came out of the
closet in Wyoming
collar combo is super that's the gayest
you're allowed to be in like [ __ ]
North Dakota so true
I love that the rhinestones
gay yeah
that's a good one and we like he's a
lbgt he's a big computer you can tell
can I watch this without getting claimed
do you think probably not absolutely not
even worth it best of Jeff Dunn and Jose
De jalapeno
just awesome thematically we don't even
have to watch it yeah so speaking of
Howie Mandel have you seen his prolapse
Tick Tock I have not
really do you know about it I don't wow
I don't
let me just Revel in this moment please
before I show it to you no absolutely
Howie Mandel family friendly comedian
yep the face actually dealer no dealer
America's Got Talent yes the man's all
over the place Bobby's World which I
kind of stole with stavy's world love
Bobby's World I love it not great show
yeah great show that one in the uh the
life of the Louis one the Louis Anderson
one love those were two bangers bro yeah
37 yeah I'm 33. we're in there okay so
so we grew up with similar cartoons
because these guys are too young they
don't yeah yeah yeah you do dude [ __ ]
these guys it's just me and you in here
baby you know you guys you hear that
guys just me and you just across the
world just us so all the cameras go dark
everywhere everything the lights are off
yeah so I'll just set this up Howie at
the time was doing a big ad campaign
with staples with this awesome so
remember that that's awesome yeah and he
lost this deal apparently
foreign
respect for help I'm going to show you
the uncensored version
he posted this on Tick Tock who's up for
17 hours okay to this day
all the comments and all of his ticked
off videos are we will not forget
he came on our podcast a few weeks ago
and we talked about this for two hours
I'm sure that's what he wanted to talk
about yeah
and so I'm gonna open it again okay
all right so here we go let's see
okay hold on where am I going to see it
I'm gonna pull it up I just got to make
sure it's unmuted right here it is so
this imagine you're at home I'm at home
scrolling Tick Tock I'm innocent yeah
Maui Mandel pops up
what the bent over this happened does
somebody know is this covid related and
if it is what do we do about it what the
[ __ ] is that oh get the [ __ ] out of here
what was
wait what did Howie say Ethan when my
friend Neil bent over this happened does
somebody know is this covid related and
if it is what do we do about it
okay so how holy [ __ ] how it comes on
the show and he tells us I didn't know
what it was I thought it was someone sat
on pudding or something what
the guy's inside out [ __ ] clear as
day yeah and so he did the whole thing
he's got the [ __ ] little green screen
effect he's looking at it he probably
took a couple takes my friend Neil bent
over this happened does somebody know
what it means related and if it is
that's what do we do about it that's
like it looks like a baboon's ass yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy just started a
whole huge debate
did it get taken did he get like
suspenders no because he's Howie Mendel
they it's 17 hours it was up though
everyone was just like what the [ __ ] I
had millions of views because everyone's
freaking out about it but still I feel
like I feel like [ __ ] gets taken down on
Tick Tock all the time you can show a
prolapse and it doesn't get taken down I
don't get it you know I mean I don't get
uh my [ __ ] gets taken down all the
[ __ ] time but I'm not Howie Mandel
with this kind of yeah what the [ __ ] is
this
[Music]
see his comment section oh yeah we will
never forget about it we won't forget I
ain't forgetting
so it's his legacy now and Howie he's
he's got to be
accomplished so much in life and he's
come so far right this is his legacy
absolutely without question for a bunch
of Zoomers no question yeah they don't
know should it be 67 67. they don't know
[ __ ] even about even dealer no deal is
too old for those [ __ ] right
this is what they know about him just
the pro he's the pro level he's the
prolapse I tell you what when he passes
I'm a chisel a prolapse on his
gravestone
how he was here and we will never forget
yeah isn't he also like a is he like
germaphobic and [ __ ] like that yeah so
wouldn't that image just disgust him
viscerally so yeah I asked him about
that apparently his germaphobia is just
about kind of what's on his body like
looking at something like so you could
look at something gross yeah yeah yeah I
also like it because
does he do a lot of like reacting to
other videos is that his thing on Tick
Tock it's still open
when when you pulled up the comments it
was in the window behind it didn't I
close it I don't see it oh [ __ ] maybe
you closed it now but I just want to
make sure it's not accidentally gonna
show up on screen okay yeah me too but
yeah to answer your question he does do
that a lot he's kind of known for
finding these weird videos and reacting
but this one's like the cake okay yeah
because I was gonna say the writing was
a little soft if you're going to show a
man's [ __ ] inside out if he thinks
it's just pudding right if he doesn't
think the image is stupid related right
why would it hurt right right if he
doesn't think it's a prolapse I would do
a little stronger I don't want to look
he's a legend I don't want to tell him
how to do his job right I would punch up
the copy a little bit instead of being
like this is what happened to my friend
Jeff is it coven related if it's not a
man's ass now if it's a guy's [ __ ]
hilarious piece of cut and you meant to
do that one of the funniest videos yeah
yeah but if you think it's pudding kind
of weird yeah kind of weak so you kind
of got to own it one way or the other oh
so here anyway that Rose to a whole next
thing where we started to have this
debate if it was a prolapse of pleasure
or pain that was a that was a pleasure
of prolapse of pleasure I would have
guessed pleasure because he had his ass
he had his pants ripped seemingly he got
his ass [ __ ] so savagely
consensually or probably fisted actually
that's a a [ __ ] can't do that kind of
damage no oh no there's very certainly
not ours we've covered that in the first
in the first before the first time
I suppose there's a couple [ __ ] in the
world that could do that kind of damage
but that's probably a first thing hard
to find I just watched cruising
with uh Al Pacino and free a freaking
movie and he goes undercover because
there's a gay serial killer and he's a
he's a maybe Gay maybe he's not we can't
he's kind of up in the air but he goes
undercover and there is a scene where a
guy gets fisted it's pretty [ __ ] sick
honestly You See It Go in you don't see
it going but you see it kind of it's
like blocked it's artfully done and the
guy's like like he's really enjoying
getting a NFL but she knows does it move
Al Pacino's [ __ ] moves a little bit you
can see you can see that on the
director's cut it's just it's just the
head cut of his it's actually another
guy has his x-ray vision and he looks at
Al Pacino's that's crazy that's crazy
but they cut that out of the whole
regular movie that's a shame well so
listen this led down a rabbit hole and
we got acquainted with this guy called
hunger FF the FF stands for fist [ __ ]
and he is the world recognized
[Laughter]
king of of prolapsing oh wow and so we
brought him on and that's not he
prolapsed life for Halloween
yeah yeah it was great dude shout out to
Howie no he's honestly I would have
thought he's past watching guys uh pop
their [ __ ] out of their ass he
thought it was just a normal Talent
I told him
that's a great one we told him uh we
wanted to put his judging skills to the
test like America's Got Talent and
hunger came out and just wow laughs yeah
live so how far is the guy standing leg
right there he was on this TV we
couldn't get on TV okay but anyway
because I was gonna say what is a what
does a live prolapse smell like it can't
smell good their [ __ ] are clean man
I don't know like you'll see in this
video I'm about to show you
those guys take care okay all right they
got their own bidet they're not sharing
up a day and say it and so what I'm
about to show you yes is some of hunger
ff's work great name by the way love it
I hung he hungers to get fist [ __ ]
yeah he's a talented man you just it's
crazy and uh this is the video we put
together kind of in the aftermath okay
great we used it uh Zach let me Hunker
in here I'm just gonna show it to you so
please try to try to not look away okay
and try to enjoy it and can you bring up
the sentimental music of it
let's see what we got here
you want to see that I showed this last
time but it's so funny I'll just show it
to you this is how we got him
yeah I want to see it
I gotta I'll stop showing this to people
I promise it was so funny I want to see
it
there's no audio
I thought you were showing the uh the
hunger video okay do I call them hunger
okay so here's that hunger yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no idea I'm waiting to see a [ __ ] 8th
grader sing yeah he wants you some
bootleg Jabberwockies do a little dance
move I was so happy
[Music]
yeah can you mind changing shirts
yeah yeah I'm sorry we just can't show I
know after all
that he says do you want me to turn it
off
tell him to change your shirt and then
he goes I was in good shape he is very
he's in [ __ ] good shape
he works with holy [ __ ] good guy what a
good guy yeah he is yes it's bad it was
stupid you shouldn't have worn that
shirt
um you have the uh the other prolapse
video oh my God oh my God oh my God
thank you how am I okay okay yeah oh
it's pause
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you know what I mean it's bad
I was on his own stream yesterday and I
typed gayporn.com into a into his video
and I kept hovering my finger over enter
uh yeah by the way um
I'm not and you know go to see go go see
yeah so so a little um sure to the
original prolapse they're not really a
prolapse just a Gaper just a huge gape
yeah which which where does it stop
being a gate where does it start being a
pro it comes out right when it comes out
so just a little bit of ass out well
it's like when does a hole become a
cylinder
great point
it's a Time old question [ __ ] dude that
actually I think that helped me
understand physics no joke yeah I think
that's the first time all right here we
go let's get through this let's get it
[Applause]
he's got a big old beard yeah so Howie
please let me conduct this go ahead yeah
thank you so hunger FF is that how you
prefer me to address you hunger
let's start by showing your talent and
then we can kind of talk through it is
that okay
yeah um just go ahead and do it right
now yeah just go ahead everything
oh my God oh my God
oh no
oh
[ __ ] I think
no that's unbelievable you should have
quit the show afterwards
that's really impressive so forgive me
for keep killing it guys
if it's actually oh wait you ain't seen
nothing yet so here's hunger's finest
work let's see it and um I'm gonna pull
it up now you ready I can't wait okay
yeah Crank That sentimental music here
we go
a minute long
oh no [ __ ] what the [ __ ] why is he
[ __ ] no what the [ __ ] that why is she
sickling it he's tickling it
that's what he looks like oh dude that
sucks
oh
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] no stop doing that stop
petting it oh no no no no no no no
not that that sucks
that that kid that's so that sucks so
bad dude I hate this
oh my God that's what it looks like you
should get you a little taste of what
help us off my God yeah it's really
incredible [ __ ] that looked like liver
that looked like a [ __ ] like liver
from the grocery store that's horrific
and I mean not to disparage hunger
because he's very obviously very
talented but holy I think Hunter hunger
understands it's a little surprising to
see for the first time that is that
hunger was that was angry yeah he was
one of them who's the other guy I don't
know another really talented artist
that can't be good for your [ __ ]
right I'm not trying to be you know I'm
not trying to Kink shame anything well I
asked him that he said actually he went
to the doctor to get examined and it
turns out you can have a um
he's like you don't even need to come
here for a
a a colonosculine
they put the finger in prostate exam
yeah they're like you can do this at you
can just do this at home in the mirror
can you pop it out let me look at it I
don't have my fingers he says his
[ __ ] is fine
I don't know about that speaking of
prolapse
my mother's cookies so you brought
cookies I did from Baltimore
I went home for Thanksgiving
and I got some cookies oh wow your mom
made these my mom made those yo shout
out to Little V little Venetia homemade
dude these are Greek Treasures Greek
Treasures we've got the brown ones those
are her utmost specialty they're called
um Mello macarona they're like a ginger
I do yeah they're like a ginger olive
oil orange I mean that's the best that's
unbelievable stuff it's olive oil olive
oil it's vegan actually oh my God just
honey if you know [ __ ] bees my wife will
love these yeah and then the white ones
there's layers there's a second layer
under the second layer bro go crazy and
then the the the white ones are called
uh curabiedes
yeah yeah you're right you heart let's
do that little [ __ ] up clipped penis
does anyone ever ask you to upgrade to
them I have been asked to talk Greek in
the middle of sex that catches me off
guard because those that's like how I
talk to my grandparents you know what I
mean right it's like not as sexy it's
like all business or like family stuff
so it's not like hot for me to be like
yeah but that is uh yes that's good a
butter cookie that's not vegan and then
this is a classic uh baklava situation
yep unbelievable that's all little
Venetia shout out to shout out to my mom
oh yeah oh yeah um
I wish we ate them before the prolapse
but they're still great
I waited yeah
on a diet yeah yeah
honestly that [ __ ] me up that guy's
ass that was crazy it's like it's it's
like I'm expecting for something to pop
out of a guy's ass but that was a lot of
meat dude that was like that's why he's
the best that's a lot dude and the guy's
stroking it he's stroking his [ __ ]
like it's a puppy I hated that dude you
could see the guys come
the craziest part is when they go ask to
ask and they [ __ ] each other with their
own asses they put their asses in each
other's asses I didn't even know that
was possible
it's awesome though yeah I gotta be
honest it's taken me a second to be like
okay I guess I see how homophobic people
feel now when they see guys kissing
because I see you guys kissing I'm like
that's obviously that's cool but that
I'm like all right I need a second put
that away I need a second to be you know
we're testing my allyship you know but
but I'm good now I wouldn't want to see
that in the park and I'm an ally trust
me I'm an ally but if that's at the
Pride Parade
you're right I think we need to adjust I
think right
no prolapse of pride you can have Kink
but no prolapse
but you know what he he's a great guy
and he's so talented he's definitely a
talent I'll give him that and he seems
like a good guy so you I noticed you
gave this to Joe Rogan he did not eat
them he didn't eat them on [ __ ] cow
did not eat them on Mike he didn't want
to eat uh while it was going on what
kind of [ __ ] is that [ __ ] you did he
eat it after he did eat it and he was
very complicated I just want to make
sure no no no he didn't he didn't snub
he didn't snub phenicia don't worry God
she's a beautiful woman sure thank you
thanks for having her back I got no
problem eating on air hell yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] your fans I think that
it's not one or the other I think it is
yeah yeah okay well [ __ ] them yeah yeah
yeah The Baklava yeah good stuff right
um no she's the best I'm trying to
convince her to make a bakery I'm trying
to put my whole family my brother's got
a gym uh I helped him start that [ __ ]
honestly strength and conditioning uh
what's it called Odyssey strength and
conditioning it's good if you have an
odyssey it's it's because you agree yeah
yeah oh that's bad Greek theme yeah yeah
uh it's going like working out is kind
of an audience it works it works
everyone's on their own little Odyssey
he named it himself
um and then my mom I'm trying to get her
and then my brother
my brother George is an artist uh you
know do I have one of George's paintings
he gave me one but yes he does art by
Jojo and he does very he does very
honestly
he might he might get prolapsed into his
thing he's his his whole thing is like
uh demons [ __ ] Angels right now he's
doing some like you know okay he's
making somebody's making some statements
but it's good he's a very talented he
checked in on him he's doing good he's
actually doing better than he has in
months like he started going to therapy
he started like exercising his
everything's going good he's like you
know and that's what comes out so you
know artists if you're depressed you
can't really create you know it's not
fun it's not fun everyone
and I swear to God her teachers this was
before we were married but living in
Israel together
she had art teachers that would tell her
you can't be you have to not be in a
relationship with him if you want to
make good art that's crazy like trying
to get her to end our relationship
that's wild I was like you guys trying
to [ __ ] you
the teacher maybe try to [ __ ] her oh
yeah
he's hot you weren't slinging dick in
Israel
I mean there was I only had one client
there was no Demand by the way either
she has a very specialized taste you
know yeah yeah some people like it
different ways thank God for that eh
absolutely oh my God thank God for that
be for her having bad making bad
decisions right bro where would we be
without women making bad decisions oh
dude the amount of women who I [ __ ] and
I'm like this is hilarious that you're
doing this right now this is this is
awesome
thank you I don't know what what fat
charismatic father figure you had
growing up that made this possible but
salute to your zany Uncle your fat uncle
that came in and grilled on Fourth of
July you know
but you said um
you're going to take some time off
because can we talk about that yeah
absolutely you're going to take some
time off and you're going to be focusing
on losing weight yeah I'm trying to get
[ __ ] yoked baby I'm trying to get
biggest just big arms a little titties
because I'm on I'm also on a weight loss
Odyssey okay I like that now yeah before
it's weight loss Journey we lost Journey
setbacks yeah the Odyssey it's all about
the [ __ ] actual it's not about the
end it's about the journey it's not
about the destinations about the whole
actual [ __ ] thing right I see an
odyssey let's see oh you got the Trojan
Horse you got the [ __ ]
we got a lot of cool stuff yeah I'm
trying to think of some Hercules
yeah fire
the heel philosophy
good book yep just the book philosophy
but there's something funny about the
journey yeah like I'm like bro you don't
got to rub it in that I'm fat I know I
know I just want to lose weight I'm not
trying to have a whole [ __ ] Journey
yeah yeah my it's also funny because
it's like I the I am fat because of me
it's like being like you're going on a
journey because yeah it's like you woke
up one day and drove eight hours in the
wrong direction and now you have to walk
back and that's what it feels like when
you're losing I guess it is a journey
but yeah I guess I got me here yeah but
a journey yeah so anyway I've been
trying to lose weight and actually it's
been good I got real big yeah
I don't know if it was pandemic or I
started some medicine that I gained like
80 pounds damn bro and I'm down like 30
now nice
but um
I was getting massive and the thing that
is working for me real good is I just do
an hour of treadmill every day nice
watch some one piece anime okay yeah
okay
and uh there's like 10 000 episodes of
it yeah so you'll never know you never
run out and that's it you know I just
it's working for me I would have nothing
with a diet nothing different no yeah
I'm being good okay I was eating like a
[ __ ] monster like at night there was
no limit bro yeah at night yeah in the
morning like ordering out uh [ __ ] you're
like second dinner ordering out second
oh no problem I mean now ordering [ __ ]
it's like I don't even I'll I'll run up
a hundred dollar seamless ubereats thing
without even thinking about it anymore
that's one of the big problems of being
successful yeah but you're doing well
now right yeah yeah I'm doing well
enough to afford whatever I want those
Postmates orders man especially when
what you want is so little like um when
you grow up poor like your dreams are so
attainable and it's just like yeah I
just want to be able to if I want sushi
I'm not I'm getting a bunch of sushi and
it's gonna cost a lot of money I got
Sushi yesterday and the lady remembered
me from I was here like eight months ago
she was just like this nice little
Japanese lady and I was like
that I'll buy even more for you and I'll
tip you fifty dollars for just a little
kindness I'm I'm thinking about my life
with this like 55 year old Japanese
woman I was ready to just move in with
her she was like I remember you from
about a couple months ago I was like you
do yeah I ordered the most expensive
[ __ ] awesome yeah left her big ass tip
hopefully she probably sure she'll never
forget me now for good so now when I go
back I I um I'm going to uh uh propose
the third time oh I wish you luck yeah
thank you I would love that I would love
an elderly Japanese wife just a mom
another mom another thing is if you
think about a fat
what mostly you know Greeks are kind of
I'm kind of like I'm a little dubious on
Greeks being fully white but let's just
say for this for the sake of this a fat
white man you don't give the Greeks the
white status I don't think I was going I
went to Greece I was like these aren't
white people like if you think about it
if you go if you go through our stats
right everyone's like a little short
hairy gaudy very loud mouth right
anti-semitic right right act well that's
why it will act very gay but are
homophobic right are Greek's
anti-semitic oh out of they're out of
control I love that well because yeah
yeah because and so I'm thinking about
if you look at the if you check the
boxes we check a lot more like error
boxes than we do white boxes oh I see
where you're going very gaudy you know
what I mean okay let's think about that
baby dude The Creeks Get the Era passed
oh for sure that tasted like Middle
Eastern uh yeah dude yeah Middle Eastern
yeah that's what I'm saying so okay cool
and I think the reason we're considered
white is because uh white people want
ancient Greece on the resume that they
kind of retconned it to get [ __ ]
philosophy the Olympics all that kind of
[ __ ] but anyway for the sake of this a
fat white man in his 30s in shape
Japanese lady in her 50s there's going
to be a point where she's younger than
me the way I age versus how she ages
right so I think it's a it's a match
made in heaven right right like when I'm
you'll die at the same age not the same
age I'll be 53 she'll be you know 70
whatever the [ __ ] it'll be so it's
perfect so but yeah I am trying to to
lose less I don't know how he got there
I've just been thinking about this
Japanese woman for the last time he
looks good she looks great honestly out
of 10 one out of ten
well you know her net you remember I
never got her name never got her name we
didn't chat much but it was there was an
undeniable chemistry in the air there
was a poll there was a yeah there was
definitely an energy
um
I don't know well look she like she's
she's pretty old so but just pure body
I'm gonna say seven wow you know for how
old she is are you into the MILF
category
um I'm typically not a big I mean listen
I'm into MILFs in that they put a lot of
lays with big ass titties and big asses
in the MILF category okay but I don't
really The Narrative of like she's my
stepmom doesn't really do much for me
mom mommy [ __ ] is not I'm not into that
or not like not the incest core which is
so popular now but just like the older
ladies no no I mean I've never I haven't
been with too many
most most the most most of the hot
people that are attracted to me are
younger than me because I think I don't
know I think there's some fantasy about
being with a big fat piece of [ __ ] if
you're like a young girl I really I
really think so I really think that's a
style I know a single man
you got to be over the top you know it's
like that it's you know I think that's
what's going on track suit kind of like
Mafia Vibe a little bit okay A little
dangerous a little dangerous I have an
anger problem you do have an anger
problem but I'm it's under control I'm
in therapy but you know that kind of are
you medicated I'm not yeah I like that
[ __ ] I'm in all kinds of [ __ ] I can't
I can't I can't have any more obstacles
around my penis whatsoever all right my
kids can't be but the thing is you seem
like you enjoy drugs too and you can't I
do love drugs yeah that's a problem yeah
I'm a little so I'm a sober kick right
now but if anything made my dick even
three percent less hard and made it so
that I couldn't take other random pills
I'm out like I'm out I get that I got a
I got a red eye tonight I don't even I
just got a handful of pills I'm gonna
take you don't even know it's gonna be
awesome yeah yeah yeah I can't wait I
love that man yeah what's in the
cocktail
um I you know well we got some edibles
we got some uh just some some
melatonin okay you know I'm gonna fall
right asleep uh I think a Xanax or
something like that though you know I
don't know they're just in a little
plastic bag if anyone if anybody has
pills in L.A and wants to give me some
before I leave uh yeah terminal five
yeah hard to miss
yeah so but actually the one thing I've
been doing yeah weight loss hit me is
I've been so Metamucil powder you know
about that yeah so I charge up on a you
can do like a full big ass cup like that
two big old scoops of Metamucil before
every meal Crush that it fills you up
interesting big time the water and the
fiber and then uh it also keeps your
blood sugar stable so you don't get
hungry huh do you take weird Jello type
[ __ ]
mm-hmm because I I did that once I got
some Metamucil and my [ __ ] came out like
like like a log of jello
it was like you you know like maybe the
60s where they would have like the like
they would serve that yellow corn it
just came like truly out of my ass
that's scary it like wobbled you know
what I mean and I was like what the [ __ ]
is it I was on my Pro Am I prolapsing is
what I was thinking you know what part
of me my [ __ ] does look different though
it looks kind of like
you know how there's like underwater
seaweed that floats up at the top it's
just like kind of formless and [ __ ] up
looking okay it reminds me of that
interesting yeah so it's long it's like
yes that's literally exactly what came
out of my ass when I did some Metamucil
that ain't right bro it was [ __ ]
weird I poked it but I was like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah then you and then
give it a taste I was like something's
wrong here but I recommend it it's
really good it's really good because you
know I'm pretty no I'm pretty sure I'm
like pre-diabetic and so the blood sugar
becomes a big issue where you want to
keep the insulin low and so I've been
trying to avoid carbs avoid sugar take
lots of fiber with all my meals okay
[ __ ] it's been good I might have to [ __ ]
around and get that fiber going dude
yeah the metamus I've just been trying
to get jacked I'm trying to get stronger
even though I'm getting fatter that's my
difference that's like in my in my
weight gain I'm at least trying to so
I've been eating I've been doing that
thing where it's like well I gotta get
protein and I'm just eating like wait
too much food you said I'm like I gotta
keep getting strong but actually the
truth is protein is the best weight loss
food okay your body
takes more energy to burn the protein
and it doesn't spike your insulin there
we go I also I love that I also use that
rationale to have Shake Shack at uh 1am
last night well
I was like I gotta I gotta work out yeah
I gotta get extra chicken tenders that's
protein yeah you know like deep fried I
know I [ __ ] know a high a high a
protein intake boosts metabolism reduces
appetite and changes several weight
regulating hormones lots of steak though
you can enjoy yourself some steak some
bacon some [ __ ] I eat lots of cheese
let's [ __ ] go so you're on like a
little keto situation maybe yeah I'm
doing it's like keto but I'm not like
super militant like I had bread this
morning okay good so just a bad diet
keto but not militant it's just like I
eat a bunch of cheese but sometimes I
also have a cake
I got you I got you cake is the enemy of
the people are you a sweet guy I'm sorry
I didn't mean to tempt you no not really
actually I'm a bratty [ __ ] I go
deep fried I like salty fast
the sweets don't really tempt me uh I
wish that your thing I'm everything it's
whatever it is every bad delicious thing
I'll eat a hundred of them whatever they
are I love it dude no finer feeling I'm
being [ __ ] up off food well you know
what there's a big scientific
breakthrough recently where um they
invented this medicine maybe you guys
can get the name of it because it's like
huge right now by Eli Lily their stock
is up like a billion percent everyone
knows this is going to be a big thing
was they developed for people who are
diabetic to regulate blood sugar and it
turns out that
it's like the most miraculous weight
loss drug ever and you take it and uh
people on average are losing like 40
[ __ ] pounds within like two months
like it's is that good for you I I don't
know that's what I'm trying to figure
out because it hasn't been FDA approved
for weight loss yet but it's on the fast
track because right now it's approved
for a diabetic yeah so I got to get my
even fatter friend to get to get
prescribed it so I could have it
apparently there are some doctors who
are willing to just prescribe it though
but yeah I mean when's the last time you
did your blood test I did I did my blood
test uh actually like a month ago I'm
good oh how's it you're good come on
guys well I don't take a little surprise
out of your voice please
everything's good everything's good I in
fact holy [ __ ]
but there is something because my
doctor's a pizza he's hot and I I
realize like I don't really want a hot
doctor because I called him and I kind
of did have the same I kind of did have
the same reaction as you where I was
like he was like he just called me and
he was like all good I was like
I mean it can't all because something's
got to be up and he was like nah you're
good I was like you want to give me any
like
what else he's like nah you're good man
cholesterol a little bit higher it's all
good he just wouldn't kill you though he
wouldn't yeah maybe I just think he's a
shitty dog like that's the thing if
you're hot you're not I don't want
someone who's hot to be my doctor hot
people haven't faced enough adversity I
want the most [ __ ] up looking person
possible you know who Society is against
give me like an ugly ass black lady
doctor right because Society is that
she's up against the most women face
them no and by the way I'm saying I want
her so don't don't try and flip this
into me being I'm saying whoever Society
tramples on yeah because you got to be
good at medicine to be a doctor she's
gonna give you she's going to tell you
straight she knows her [ __ ] other than
like a sexy guy with nice hair some
white guy with piercing blue eyes six
three I don't want him ABS I don't want
a doctor with absence that's true he
probably could [ __ ] bat his eyelashes
understand your life if that lady looked
at your truck she'd be like you're
[ __ ] dead tomorrow you don't change
exactly exactly and I'm listening to her
because Society didn't want her to be a
doctor
she [ __ ] persevered here it is Lily's
uh terzeptide terzapatide
all right dude apparently you know how
to [ __ ] with everything I'm horrible at
reading today there's appetite delivered
up to 22.5 weight loss in adults with
obesity are overweight that's insane I'm
in there dude give me that [ __ ] I'll
do that I'll do the [ __ ] up diet pills
from like Saved by the Bell I don't give
a [ __ ] yeah but I'll do I'll do any kind
of pill to lose weight the thing is yeah
because well back in the day they would
give people like speed to lose weight
but it's not but this ain't it this is
just like it's just it just makes you
not hungry
and uh I'm in there too it actually
sounds super compelling so this is
basically the Dream Work
we
we can keep eating that's the dream I
want to keep eating yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah just enough though and a drug makes
me stop at a regular time well you know
Louis Armstrong uh he wrote a book about
how to lose weight using um
using uh
diarrhea diet stuff that makes you have
diarrhea really use a man have ahead of
his time wow that's actually called an
eating disorder guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm not I'm not that's a tough
co-signing it if anyone's the plug on
precipitide let me know I'm trying to
take some here you are and uh apparently
I'm ready to go two months is this
camera
that's nice dude yeah I'm trying to get
like that all right we got Jimmy on the
on the phone oh this is our comedian
that needs help I can't wait so let's
bring on Jimmy Lee let's bring on James
he's a fan favorite standby well
[Music]
um
they're corn there's two kids they're a
very mixed reception
Jimmy's a hot dog he's a dentist by the
way okay he's actually a very
successful dentist he owns different
Dentistry offices and wow the way we
there he is oh all right hey pink say
there he is Pink's Hot Dog wait why whoa
where's the hair Jimmy where's the
iconic hair
uh he has not connected his audio yet
okay that we found him
is that he had a comedy uh sketch that
he filmed that he was passing out to his
clients on a disc yeah on a seat on a
DVD
and one of our fans sent it to us that's
awesome and this was years ago and uh
we've been close friends ever I love it
Jimmy you there hello
yeah hold on okay oh yeah get ready I'm
here I gotta get the audience
wait Jimmy what's with the hat where's
the hairline
no hairline pinks pinks hot dogs today
wait we're celebrating pinks was your
makeup person not available what
happened
[Music]
hairline nobody knows
I will we'll keep it a secret
Prince is the best pinks Ethan's the
best hot dog place in La they got all
different flavors of hot dogs
that's what Mr Pink asked me to say I'm
reading off the sheet
okay well shout out uh Pink's Hot Dogs
apparently yeah um Pink's Hot Dogs rules
sure does
we so so Jimmy this here is Stavros how
we doing Jimmy
uh well I want to thank you guys for
having me on that was a very a nice
surprise Merry Christmas and very nice
to meet you yeah Jimmy we love you Jimmy
we're always happy to have you on where
are you from Julie I'm sorry the accents
uh New Jersey Jersey Outlaw yeah
Philadelphia accent yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting I'm from Baltimore
it's a little twinges of that
Mid-Atlantic accent yeah just a little
bit over there yeah yeah so go ahead so
um Stavros is actually a very successful
comedian I don't know if you know him
but he has a special out it's going
viral on YouTube right now Jimmy it has
4.1 million views
that's 4. million views more than I have
yeah yeah you'll get there Jimmy I'm I'm
hoping before uh
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
but you're making Goods you're speeding
along huge strides so Jim you know what
I'm doing you know I got my Show's doing
how's that I normally only God who knows
about it right
a little old-timey humor I see okay so
Jimmy um how would you describe your
brand of Comedy for Stavros
offensive old style uh insult comedy oh
all right
let's hear it bro you want to go you
want to try
um do you want to maybe try roasting
stuff yeah yeah or before yourself well
I I watched them earlier and I I would
tell you nothing gets by and especially
carbohydrates
okay you got me there all right roasted
I mean I'm roasted
what's your first name Stavros so stop
rush you want to hear something cool
about Las Vegas I'd love to if you don't
bring your girl they actually send one
up it's pretty cool Zach tried it yeah
that's just prosecution
no no I didn't say that you said that
yeah I'm pretty sure you have to ask
well well wait a minute you know the
cool thing about about hookers in Vegas
oh what's that they can drop it drape it
and droop it
drop it draping and drooping would that
be their [ __ ] is that what you're
kind of relating their [ __ ] they're
better no don't push don't push oh he
doesn't like follow-up questions
because it's hard sometimes it's hard to
explain right right exactly the mark of
a good joke
it stands up to zero scrutiny whatsoever
exactly I was telling AB I had so much
gas least that I thought I was being
followed by Arabs
I guess they were trying to take the gas
from you because typically the Arabs
have the gas but again we don't have to
follow up it's about an interesting
observation Jimmy you know what Ethan
said you know what Ethan said what's
that
he said let me let me get this straight
the Arabs get the oil and the Jews cut
off the tips of their what
right that's just that's really there's
no punch line that's just what the Way
It Is Well you know uh Arabs are
circumcised too Jimmy I don't know if
you knew that correct are you kidding me
yep
what's your [ __ ] look like Jimmy he's uh
you clipped when I when I come out there
I'll show it to you it's not that
difficult it's about two inches hard it
was just hard you're in the company my
friend
you'll fit right in
I'm a little pissed off at Kanye West
about all those Jewish jokes you know oh
yeah why is that yeah well he's
anti-semitic I don't know if you heard I
did hear that he could be German
he may wear the armband I don't know
what he's doing he doesn't like Jewish
people I happen to be Jewish
it's hard to tell because your rhythm is
so natural and conversational when
you're joking and when you're just
having a chat Jimmy actually speaking of
Kanye we discovered today there's a
Ratatouille situation going on with him
I don't know have you seen the movie
Ratatouille
his every move so that might clear
things up for you a little bit it's not
his now now I fully understand I
appreciate that
all right so so I guess we're done
roasting Sovereign
[Applause]
comes out one at a time that's good what
happened a card comes out it says one at
a time you know how there's cards and
scales
[Laughter]
he was on the corner the other day the
cops tried to get him to break it up
that's a little you're pushing it oh I'm
pushing it I just told you don't push
just break them up because he's too big
right right can I tell you can I tell
you something that happened to me when I
was 12.
yeah
my father taught me how to swim he put
me in a canoe in a lake in the canoe
capsized and I got to tell you Ethan it
was tough getting out of that burlap bag
tried to drown you huh
all right stop with those damn crickets
how about them
that's tragic I'm sorry to hear that
yeah okay so so we're done we're gonna
move past the stravos roast very good so
let's do a set oh wait a minute wait a
minute I forgot to tell you something
what's that do you like my hat from
Pink's Hot Dogs I don't know if I
mentioned it he didn't no no you didn't
yeah so I I uh I eat it pinks when I got
to La they got really great hot dogs and
um all different flavors and it's a
great place I mean that's how Mr Right
he asked me to read it wait wait oh this
isn't a joke no we missed it Mr Pink
asked him to read it
yeah it was uh Mr Pink asked me to read
it
I don't know if I told him I don't get
it
punch on his he this is an ad after all
is that am I am I on
am I close wait oh no you you missed it
you're right I'm the one who doesn't
understand
I got another pink thing tell me please
Ethan did I tell you something can I
tell you something yeah I'm wearing my
pinks I'm wearing my pinks hat today I
don't know if you saw it I don't know I
like yeah I didn't know if I mentioned
it to you if I'm wearing my pinks at
today they have really good hot dogs in
L.A really good place to go eat right
Yeah you mentioned oh yeah yeah you said
that oh I did mention I wasn't sure I
mentioned it I apologize okay this is
good this is like anti-comedy
on it today all right let's get so you
cassette right
so I'm so now Jimmy remember you're here
for feedback okay
okay
because we want you to be successful and
we want you to perfect your craft now I
think you would admit you're not a
perfect stand-up comedian you have some
stuff to learn right
I have so much to learn according to
Zach that I should be a dentist not a
comedian that's what he keeps saying me
stick to your dental job right so I'm
trying to and he is right by the way but
go ahead and he is right by the way I
think I think anyone would tell you that
and if they're not they're they don't
like you but anyone in your life telling
you to to give up your very successful
dental practice to pursue stand-up
comedy is actually your enemy I want you
need to understand that but hey you'll
be proud of me though I signed a
five-year deal with Harris casino last
week in Vegas did you yeah now I'm
waiting for them to sign
right that's funny that's funny I like
that all right I guess so let's get to
this so hold on hold your horses there
oh wait a minute wait a minute
no you wait a minute I gotta I gotta put
this train back on the rails yeah okay
so we have here off the rails we have
here a great very funny very Talent
you've been in comedy for how long 10
years yeah 13 years 13 years of
experience so Jimmy I want you to do
your set but what I'll ask is that you
be a little receptive if he has feedback
or criticism or I'm not here to
criticize we're here uplift to uplift so
so but but if if Stavros wants to stop
and give commentary let's just try to
learn okay
could I tell them about my doctor okay
so please we're starting okay go ahead
yes my doctor I said is my heart's
strong enough for sex he said not if I
join in
because you'd be so attracted to your
doctor would make your heart beat so
fast is that what you're getting at
you're in closet homosexual
no no no I tried to come out of the
closet Zach followed me out okay so you
are oh you're out well gotcha and Jack
and I fly we sit in the cockpit so you
go figure okay so in the cockpit while
the well the Pilot's trying to fly
you're you and Zach are sucking each
other's [ __ ] is what you're saying no
no playing with each other's not sucking
oh just playing okay all right thank you
all right good I would make that clear
that doesn't like does doesn't Zach
doesn't like that other thing
but he's tried a bit of a pillow
princess
I think we need to give Jimmy some
poppers you know
I don't like it I took Zach on a
vacation though okay how'd that go you
know the cool well everybody comes it's
fun
I've heard that joke a lot of times yeah
I like that one so so I have another
joke please that's good but I would say
try and make it a little more seamless
and not in terms of transitions
Jimmy hold on dude what is going on with
you and pink
there's something there's something
going on Jimmy Lee oh I don't know if I
told you I'm wearing my pinks hat today
yeah you are
you
Yeah you mentioned it
I didn't mention it so I'd like to tell
you what happened last night to me okay
so go on you you were just what happened
last night yeah well I came home and my
wife was in her nightgown and at the end
table in the Hatchery which is a
Sigourney but it was lit it was a lit
sigour and I said honey where'd that
cigar come from and the voice in the
closet said would you believe Havana
right okay that's pretty good by the way
I think Stavros gave you um useful
feedback that we kind of lost over you
said you finish one joke and then to set
up the other one you said I have another
joke and right did you think maybe as a
transition I would say so I would rate
that transition 0 out of ten and then I
would say what you want to do is kind of
maybe tack it onto your the the last
idea into the next one I just just like
so for example Havana we all laughed go
into the next joke naturally let's hear
what you got
oh I could tell you what uh What uh
Tyson said the Holyfield okay great he
said I ain't going down without a snack
that's I like that because it's topical
that's probably my favorite part of it
Holyfield Holyfield said I can't hear
you I can't hear you Tyson handed in
Missouri said can you hear me now can
you hear me now right that's good
because it's topical and I think also
referencing a cell phone commercial from
uh 10 years after that happened that's
kind of a nice a nice little mix of
Errors there you know what bill you know
what Bill Clinton said another time wow
no well I want to tell you Bill Clinton
was the only president to come between
two bushes
would you believe that Jimmy just
finished College during the Clinton
Administration he's around 25 yeah
according to Jimmy do you know what Bill
Clinton said Zach he said I'm not
wearing any pants Monica how do you like
me now that's just factual that's not
having a joke
Dorian right right right hey Jimmy how
old are you again
what was the age you told us I'm not
asking for your real number I'm in my
mid-50s don't push
see don't you really got something with
don't push by the way that's what it is
I like to be a new t-shirt yes
absolutely we need merch
Jack Jack could I tell you something
sure Jimmy
uh I got my Pink's hat on today that was
a pink taco yesterday
this is good because the only reason
he's on here is to get paid from pinks
without a doubt the [ __ ] phone he was
beginning outside pinks
[Applause]
he usually has this incredible hairline
oh yeah I was gonna say a hairline would
really help this act I think I don't
really do you think you like my hair I'd
love to see your hair yeah yeah
I think you're like you're doing
everyone a disservice hiding out of the
Pink's hat I can't do it because because
I I was in pinks I had a weird hat today
okay they don't serve a hot dog unless
you were in the Hat Jimmy uh Jimmy got
his hairline done because he met Roger
Goodell so he's a full full makeup we
met Roger Goodell at Michael's
Restaurant big shout out to Michael and
he has a restaurant out in Santa Monica
we had a beautiful lunch we were invited
in and next to the other table was
Brenda Vaccaro who was an actress many
years ago who I didn't know she was but
my photographer was quite a bit older
mentioned she was a famous actress wow
so we had a lot of fomo at Michael's
about time he had a lot of fomo a lot of
fun so you travel with a photographer
you have like a traveling Entourage
he's spending a lot of money to make
this game happen can I tell you
something stop
nowhere he's literally spending his life
savings to make this do you have
children yeah 23 million dollars on this
and my wife says maybe you should quit
because you're not going anywhere and I
said I'm 23 million in maybe you're
right I may have to quit yeah yeah no
you she's right you're right that's not
a real number how much you spend on this
22 22 million 22 million that's a little
better that's a lot better for sure
um yeah hold on let me see that cup
Jimmy
hold it they asked me to be the
centerfold for Reader's Digest let me
see that
wait a minute they asked me to be the
senator I asked you first yes can I ask
you something I don't like why they put
those damn Staples I ain't doing it all
right they put them on your [ __ ] I see
what do you got there
what is that brand oh I think it's Wawa
you know Ethan I got a guy working for
me 12 years and one year he gets bar
mitzvah
you you're working with a child Jimmy
12 years
thank you for the
proud Jimmy where do you see this going
ultimately where do you think is like uh
nowhere I'm trying to get famous doing
Street comedy and uh I'm having a rough
time yeah I think my stuff's too too old
school yeah yeah I keep hearing the same
three words from everybody you're not
funny right constantly here and then
like he appearance Zach and Ethan text
me three words quit the business
[Laughter]
and he texts them like 10 times a day I
gave them in my email I looked recently
he's emailed me like 450 times Jimmy do
you have an empty personal life or
what's going on here I I grew up with uh
parents that weren't kind of there for
me I didn't get the love as a kid so now
you're yes I I have that void and we
talked about that uh podcast in May yeah
we may have diagnosed him with
histrionic personality history
do that right yeah we should you should
meet a psychiatrist for sure have you on
a therapy ever Jimmy this is by the way
security
so it's a big budget production are you
is this okay
you're not in charge of this you're part
of like a prank that someone's pulling
is that what's going on Jimmy
this can't be your ideas huh according
to Zach yes Stovers he spends thousands
on them
this is awesome dude
can I ask the comedian artist can I ask
him an honest question because I wanted
to understand
um am I going anywhere with this or am I
going into the crapper what do you think
I would say what's most interesting the
crapper as performance art you're doing
something really interesting right right
a man ruining his life and and putting
his savings down the drain for a Dr that
you're not even doing the thing is
you're not even doing comedy you
understand that right Jimmy you're just
sort of what am I doing you're just
gonna go you're just kind of you've
hired people and you speak outside right
like have you been on a stage or
anything like that what would you like
to see stand up I did stand up for four
years oh you did it for four years would
you like to see some of this I would
like you know what maybe I'm being harsh
I would like to see the street comedy
show some of the really good ones you
guys know what I'm talking about I sent
you two new reels put them up
juice the reels Ethan come on the [ __ ]
by the way thank you Bella Simmons
Legend
um so Jimmy but but that that's actually
true because the comedy dream has
negatively affected your professional
life hasn't it
well my wife says sometimes you're
focused too much on it and you lose
track of your job but I I comport mental
lies and I do my best but I really I am
a dreamer I'm a very good business guy
and I'm a dreamer you know and I always
say something celebrated over the Antics
or something no I had said to you a
while back that um Dennis we interviewed
had seen the street company he said he
didn't want to work for me because it
was offensive I go it's a joke it's
comedy on the street that's all it is
and the guy took it serious he didn't
realize it was just a joke and a carrot
so wait how did he see the street comedy
he knew you before he came in or did you
show it to him I no I didn't show it to
him I think when people were getting out
it cross cross contaminates into the
Jimmy Lee all right so let's take a look
here the complete fomo of Jimmy Lee if
you want no that's not jokes though
don't use that rule do a street comedy
rule so he can see do the best comedy
reel that you don't want the complete
fomo well that's fomo but it's not jokes
that just shows fomo and a celebrity
that's celebrity that's a celebrity
as they pull up a clip I'll I'll just
show this to stuff yes oh you got one
okay okay yeah some of these are so I
mean he asked you do I have a shot right
let's at least be fair you're right
you're right you know um
all right so hold on hold on hold on
just is this a good time now you have
chapters Jimmy you know you have
chapters this one's called black chicks
black chick s I'm telling you
I don't know if you knew that I love
that one I do not stop I swear this time
I'm not joking it actually says it
literally says black chicks oh geez I
don't know how that came up with her
play it for him
let's see it
costume jewelry immigration paper oh
that one's gonna be rough
Ted Kennedy honeymoon the Queen the
queen Pearl Harbor okay
um
I don't know what that is Eddie Murphy
yeah
you know Jimmy really wants us to see
the reels right Jimmy is that would you
like I want the comedian to see if I
have yeah just be honest so should I
watch the black chick segment here guys
yeah okay let's go ahead and watch that
go to the best New York roast that's
really funny real best New York right
I've already got one
okay fine let's start with this let's
start with this and then I want to see
basketball can you turn it up please
invest in your gross or reels
the best New York grocery the best NYC
roast best NYC roast
yeah can we get some more volume please
yeah it's up but we get some more you
guys like my pink set
I actually am trying to really like it I
do honestly I didn't know if I mentioned
it
that's good it's a good bit
um it's not okay Jimmy hold on we're
gonna have to you're gonna have to give
us a minute to wash this okay
now if you don't fool around on a first
date I'll drop you off go around the
corner and pick you up but be our second
date you wanna do that we could do it
Shania okay respect should I give the
Jersey out a little love
that's like yeah right and Keith get
your hand out of your pocket your hair
on your palm stop doing that so Shania
you ever you ever hear of a sandwich
shop you ever eaten a sandwich shop
okay we're gonna
sandwich shop
[Laughter]
in the morning she makes your pancakes
you can't go wrong keep the black chick
makes your pancake go get it what do you
mean what happened here we go I want to
see the one where where he made fun of
the old lady with the bandage over right
that was from our we went out and did a
shoot
okay so so let's talk about the black
chicks segment as you as you titled it
show them show them show them the best
NYC roast it's this year it's really
good I'd love to see that one do you
have any comments on on that segment yes
I think absolutely that's it that's it
let them watch that real quick let's do
some feedback so from just off the
beginning I would say Jimmy that you
there is something there is a quality
I'm enjoying to these videos right I
don't think it's something you're doing
on purpose as of right now and I think
if you can harness that you know what I
almost think you are on the right track
for the absolute wrong reasons right
like that video is kind of like the
producers you know how they tried to
make like if I tried to make shitty
comedy I would do everything you're
doing right if I if I had to sit down
and write uh but it turns out it's very
interesting
and you're you are because you have no
um filter I wouldn't the filter sure
let's say filter yeah because it's so
unfilled because you're telling such
truths
um
that because you have no I'm gonna say
shame more than filter it was kind of
what I was looking for attacked yeah
yeah exactly you're willing to bust bust
past the uh uh you know Common I would
say decency the politeness the
politeness yes and you would get in
there so that is something that's
interesting because there was a you were
tapping into an interesting energy an
uncomfortable energy for sure but right
something very interesting happened in
the for example making those two people
that were either glasses shopping or
working at the glasses store uh simulate
having a threesome with you was pretty
funny
um but they were but there was I again I
wouldn't the joke was in and of itself
was not very good but there was some
kind of special interesting quality of
watching you do it it's like a Nathan
Fielder kind of thing there is a Nathan
Fielder situation which is good don't
get me wrong you might be onto something
uh uh Jimmy uh show them show them the
best NYC
but I'll say this I'll say this Jimmy
you're more on to something than I
thought you would be
but thank you but it's we also got to
look at the p l statement right because
if if it's a problem well that's that's
where we're starting to have problems
okay because is this sustainable and if
not I actually think it makes it funnier
but it's bad for you for me it's funny
because you might be draining your you
know life savings in the pursuit of I'm
not draining my life saved well not yet
not yet no no no but I I'm a dreamer as
well as a business guy and I I have that
dream and listen if this is your art and
you're your own uh your the problem is
Ethan said it was more like a nightmare
that's the problem there we go let me
Jim but Jimmy are you are you are you
hearing him like are you hearing stuff I
I listened to what he said I'd like to
see the best NYC rush and then we'll
we'll come back
that's right so this is your this is
your your Magnum it's a new rail oh yes
this is hot this is here okay let's go
let's take a look please
the best NYC Road
the best reactions faith that Humanity
equals for stores let's hop right in
quiet
is it up all the way yeah you gotta
listen you got yeah just play the video
you'll be fine I think I'm telling you
again you're a good what do you mean
I'll be fine
all right make make it louder
what to do
C has problems Ethan if you know the
video Jimmy knows the solution if you
play the video I think he's writing it
so yeah
[Music]
inside
I love the music
that you better not forget me playing
[Laughter]
go over the bridge and then drown the
three kids and collect the insurance
money it's not that difficult to do so
he's the kids yeah put them in a home
right off the Jump you're telling these
people to kill their kids
again Jimmy really funny an insane thing
to say to someone but I'll give it to
you that is really I'll give it to you
because you're doing things that should
get you [ __ ] up let them see more
I love this favor you stay out of gay
boys I'll stay in them in front of a big
shoe do you see this guy me and this guy
represent the largest penis size
differential in the history of New York
City today listen to me you're shrinking
did you take preparation
I got a blow up doll now takes my breath
away oh yeah oh yeah let the air out of
her she flies
I found him my daughter's a lesbian I
took her to the mall she got designer
dikes Nikes yep foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Rob white she's excellent he's my New
York guy he's only about 12 10 grand a
pop
but you can't my many does that cancel
my money more than I do
here we go here we go I did one back in
the day it was right there
Joey come here put the camera down Joe
they want us they want to see you
there's some I've been drinking
everybody's right here behind the camera
I bet you when you guys I can hear you
take a look at these goddamn ears I bet
everything you say he can hear
everything you say I know something and
that's my favorite when he finds people
and then just basically just bullies
them right right right right right yeah
I find that to be competitive you don't
know tell me she used to like the
quarter pounder but when she met you she
fell in love with the Whopper
[Laughter]
who is this guy
you made some bad decisions let's talk
what made you jump in was it the money
because it's not worth all the money in
the world to sleep with this guy all
right he's a premature ejaculate every
time I hang out with him he leaves early
which one's available for the
celebrities you
group sex
the problem with that is I won't know
who to thank okay let's okay I think
here's a question I have for you Jimmy
ultimately where do you see
Street comedy taking you right because
this let's see p l Pro get back to the p
l this is not applicable to the stage
right you can't charge tickets for this
no so are you hoping to make money on
the internet
I was hoping because the comedy is
different than anybody does today it's
more like a Don Rickles comedy on the
street that because it's so different
with no filter and no one does it and
it's not accepted anymore right that
some son's a [ __ ] would grab it and get
me famous I don't seem to be working too
well that is a let me tell you right now
that will never work that is that plan
is doomed and I would say
um you got to think about building your
own base here if it's going to work for
you Jimmy you need hardcore Jimmy heads
because no one's and I hate to tell you
I work in comedy there's actually
so many people that do exactly this much
better than you do it right like I said
being honest I hate to tell you that
there are the Dom Rickles thing is
around how much comedy do you watch uh
let's start there
well I'm old school so I'm always
watching the older ones so my stuff
stated so I don't watch Comedy with the
newer guys I watched a lot of the old
roast and a lot of the stuff when I was
a kid sure I'm being honest with you so
that's why you see that old style what I
would say and I love the old style I
have no problem with the old style I
think you are onto something but you got
to let go of anyone picking it up and
just figure out that you have to carve
out your own Niche here these are
hilarious videos and I will watch these
um well that's a compliment you actually
are comedian like it so do you want me
to just try to go viral on social media
I know what you're thinking no no no no
I want you to do more root canals and
never do comedy again but when I oh geez
I'm kidding I'm kidding that's for the
carb jokes you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
screwed out of Christmas
it's bad enough that you screwed me out
of Christmas you know I don't get that
but we get you we yeah
so we get back at you
am I Santa in that anyway
um oh I got something to tell you I got
something to tell you I forgot please
I'm wearing my pinkies
Jimmy hold that thought so this is the
video we made with him we we went out on
the street and filmed the whole Jimmy on
the street special and this is one
moment from it that really got me good
okay great yeah
you end up in the emergency room
table 37 leave
it got my eye on you hon got my eye on
you
see this is see Jimmy this is
your favorite Channel you and Don
Rickles is that those people paid money
to see Tom Rickles this is some lady
with an infection that's trying to have
brunch and some [ __ ] [ __ ] shows up
and she's like hey you dumb [ __ ] you
can't even see and then he films it for
some reason
that's what to me is interesting
artistically that this shouldn't exist
now wait a minute let me ask you a
question
show off the water off the rail so it's
funny as hell so somebody will will like
it and grab it because it is offensive
yeah and I know what I'm doing I know
what I'm doing I'm doing it to go under
attention and get famous and and be
different I know what I'm doing and I I
know all the things you said I'm not a
dum-dum sure I don't think you are and
you're and you're laughing so it's got
to be somewhat entertaining it is me
once in a while and has me on but can
you go anywhere with it and get an Roi
but how does it scale brother let's talk
let's talk realistically what's what's
the next step what you have to tell you
I'm saying someone picks it up who and
where do they put it it's just like are
you saying Netflix is gonna is doing
like a special view on the street is
that how you see it
I I say it that I'm on a journey and I'm
hoping it ends up in a good spot that's
what I see but it doesn't sound like
it's going there now when you start when
you were in dental school were they like
hey just [ __ ] we'll figure it out or
they're like where's their steps you had
to do step by step there were steps
right but he's not a comedy Odyssey so
I'm just telling you you can't you need
a little bit more of a plan now here's
what I'm going to tell you keep making
this this is great stuff right I
appreciate that I'm enjoying it honestly
you got to enjoy the process because you
know how they say you're on a journey
and it's about the journey not the
destination
um okay enjoy the journey right who
knows what the destination is my guess
probably on your YouTube page I think
we're already at the destination but
just keep it going just keep enjoying it
you know if this is it too too fresh for
like TV and stuff just too offensive and
people get upset I don't don't think
that's the case I think that actually is
interesting that it is and also it isn't
what you consider to be very offensive
right
um because it's not I mean it's some of
it is bad but I've definitely seen more
offensive than this it's just kind of
like your mix of like you said your uh
all your references and everything you
remember is all the older they are older
girls so there is something very
interesting to you doing this style of
Comedy poorly in 2023 right or 2022.
because that's the other thing you you
it takes a long time to master this you
have not you're you're not even close
right okay so you at least you're being
honest with me but but
that is interesting that you have
because the imbalance between your
confidence and your abilities is so high
that it makes a very interesting piece
of art and your willingness what I will
give you credit for is your willingness
to just mix it up get in there [ __ ] with
people again not they didn't deserve it
they're just on the street right right
you're not they didn't pay to see you
and I'd also like to see you try
different for different you know let's
not let's take it out of the street
let's we've tried that it's not it's not
good yeah we've tried that I'd like to
reverse he always reverse
yeah you always revert on the street
girl yeah hold on one second this
actually has a good ending your
hairline's worse than mine what's your
name hey Jewish Kid Lawyer cantler
doctor Auto Parts Auto Parts yeah I've
seen better bodies on used car lots
that's a good one I'll give you that one
he's just saying his wife looks like
[ __ ] I love that Zach wants to say
something to you Jack's Hair I know
exactly I told him that earlier I got my
eye on her
back we're back to the well he's angry
right and rightfully so right no and he
says keep it off
it wouldn't be awesome if that guy
[ __ ] you up Jimmy I gotta be honest
you I would have loved that yeah that's
why we got to security
he knows have you ever been in danger
has anyone ever tried to fight you not
really it's just to make me look famous
I got a problem I got histrionic
personality disorder
self-diagnosed self-diagnosed and
recently no Dr Fidel Dr Fidel oh Fidel
poor doctor Fidel there was a fan of the
show that was a psychiatrist yeah and he
called in to diagnose Jimmy
I think the doctor might have had a
little history on it though because he
was like taking off his shirt and
flexing and he's like I'm in the
hospital right now
she's great I love what got him in
trouble
the extended Universe where it's like
you got that doctor you got the security
guys all right well there it is uh Jimmy
uh uh I've gotten you all the feedback
yeah I've been I mean I hope it's worth
its weight in gold no you it it really
is because now I know I gotta focus on
Dental
[Laughter]
I keep making this Jimmy but I'm just
saying you know it I wouldn't bet my
life on this becoming a money maker You
Got to Do It For the Love of the Game
and once okay I appreciate you being
honest and if it does
who knows Kudos you know you're doing
pretty good numbers here but I got a
feeling that you're spending a lot of
money for you know I don't know how much
ad Revenue wait you gotta watch this one
is so iconic this is the first video of
his I think I saw or the second this is
the first street comedy one where you're
walking around with the two models in uh
Miami oh look at the girls yeah yeah
that was a long time ago oh but that was
South Beach
show it your hairline looks good by the
way back then
I I had a little more hair the Jersey
[ __ ] hello live Miami Beach
South Beach Florida we're here shooting
today our comedy TV reality show
dangerously funny the Jersey animal has
arrived I am a funny guy what happened
to that you used to have a slogan I'm a
funny guy did you drop that I'm a funny
guy did you drop it what happened listen
to that muscle memory he brought it
right out
Zach has uh you know worked with me and
you know don't push don't pushes it I'm
telling you don't push is what you need
all right Carly get a shirt going don't
push Carly watch hold on hold on hold on
let's watch a little bit okay
how much you pay these women do you
remember how much plenty
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's my song I wrote too
four minutes
that's awesome dude exactly talented
music yeah no you clearly do have yeah
there's Talent here this video is second
whatever you were four minutes 26
seconds it's
legendary moment this whole thing is
yeah the whole thing is but this thing
is incredible yeah
your uncle
well again it's good that's awesome but
you would say it's crazy you would say
that but I wouldn't say it on the Jersey
animal I am the [ __ ] Jersey Outlaw
and I do want the Jersey Outlook needs I
love this crazy I love this because you
have no you don't understand comedy at
all but you feel completely you have
like a love of the worst parts of it and
that's what's awesome that's again as an
art piece this is incredibly compelling
because you have taken away the
craftsmanship the joke writing the life
you're reading and all you have is
trying to offend people and being out of
pocket and it does make for compelling
[ __ ] but it is again not Netflix okay
the first show yeah this whole video is
just iconic and you just have these
stored in your head is there like a
preparation for this do you write these
down do you have what do you do you have
a database yeah writing for years but I
have a photographic memory so whatever
the situation is and they pop right out
ready to go love it
yeah
all the [ __ ] money the black guy's a
multi-millionaire
jewelry
what's going on here take the glasses
off you're making a spectacle to
yourself
and then that's what a beautiful
juxtaposition he calls a black guy Uncle
Tom and then he makes a spectacle pun
right afterwards that's the difference
like the highs and lows are unbelievable
the corniest most [ __ ] jokes you've
ever heard in your life and just the
most offensive [ __ ] for no reason you're
a beautiful blend Jimmy I'll give you
that I am again I am compelled of every
moment I'm watching oh my God
you like my Pink's hat it's really good
oh God I thought I thought you said it
yeah yeah that would have been awesome
oh I want to do a discount massage
parlor I thought it was self-service
I think you were I don't think I was pal
let's [ __ ] relax here for a second
please
it's fascinating to me about Jimmy too
is that he's kind he's rather sensitive
yes and so but he comes out and he's
guns blazing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey don't push don't push again that's
another another beautiful another
beautiful you know contradiction in the
whole yeah in the in the Jimmy in the
Netflix here we come
don't even
I love the stings between hold up hold
up
where are we going
what is it the last time I went to this
place I ordered the shrimp and came home
with the crab I'm not going back Jimmy
that's a car that's not a restaurant
you're getting a pizza
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hey I shot an elephant once in my
pajamas now he got my pajamas I am
absolutely right now
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and that's why it's so good that's why
I'm the Jersey yes
[ __ ] the conventions [ __ ] the
conventional [ __ ]
um
[Laughter]
and then I dated a French girl she
showed up at the date with details went
under her arms
you're all right let me see your
immigration you're all right hey you're
all right
this is awesome dude
let's go here we go
there's some really special moments in
this
wait is that the restaurant or yeah
let's cut that that's a little bar and I
got the model to the one side and I'm
just doing it I'm doing basically you
know a Vaudeville just like you know
it's like a beach it's like Charlie yeah
it's a visual yeah
visual art
visual visuals
do you know what slapstick is what is
slapstick but what about that with slime
sitting next to a hot woman what was the
joke no it was the other person you have
to watch it okay
no no again I was the one who missed it
should I go back yeah yeah you know what
let's go
now it's not that good I'm [ __ ]
second ago I missed it well which one is
it Jimmy yeah
so am I watching him on the right no I
like this and then he either slow it
down yeah let's go slow just watch the
other person all right I'm gonna slow it
down Jimmy so we don't miss a second and
you can break this down first oh come on
no don't go slow motion just watch
the normal well I don't want to miss it
again
slapstick couldn't you break it down
break it down you sound like P Diddy
break it down
off the cuff no riffing's Gonna Save you
here Jimmy
no no I'm serious
you gotta watch at regular speed
I'll give him out
of that line we'll give it to you all
right let's go regulars babe There we go
one more time from the top from the top
okay
so watch the person on the right not the
girl that's the good looking girl watch
I'm watching him but really there wasn't
much of a reaction
nothing happened Jimmy
your son's a [ __ ]
he had a reaction
why did that make the edit Jimmy
oh [ __ ] because it was so bad that it
was good yeah there it is
Jimmy Unleashed
he thought he was the outlaw before just
watch him now
oh yeah
the Spanish
he's still slipping don't worry about it
you're a Spanish guy yeah you see your
papers
you're funny you're pretty funny yeah
funny looking don't feel
part two
okay
yeah so I'm keeping an eye on him
look who's here Isaac Hayes
now that's funny that's funny
uh Isaac Hayes is bald isn't he no but
you got to watch yes it's really funny
it's crazy
Isaac Hayes died in 2008 by the way yeah
yeah thank you for that thank you
holy God you're one guy your son your
son yeah I got a good tan what's her
name that's Jasmine not Jasmine
what's your name and like everyone's
energy no one he doesn't want to be here
at all the contempt camera the contempt
they have for Jimmy right so what I wait
to what I say
all right I can't wait
Jessica can I ask you a question when
you guys make love do you would you say
you make love on a daily basis or weekly
basis
[Music]
on a daily basis or weekly basis
show you make love on a daily basis or
weekly if I'm a good mood tonight so if
you're in a good mood okay and when he
makes love Jasmine would you say he's
one of these boom boom booms quickies or
is he one of these passionate lovers oh
it's very passionate really do you have
any videos because the girls are a
little kinky
that's it
that long sound to ask them hey by the
way can I see any videos of you [ __ ]
why did you ask me about the daily and
the weekly thing there was no quicker
way to get to that I know what a setup
is Jimmy
you got to work on the setup economy a
little too long
a little too long yeah because you see
you see how people think there's going
to be some joke about the weekly versus
daily thing but that's kind of a red
herring and it's really just a way to
ask them to see a video of them [ __ ]
you understand how the setup doesn't
really connect to the punchline that's
all I'm saying I would consider a setup
economy but I also don't want to I don't
want to step in and give you any
pointers because what you do is perfect
as is yeah yeah for you it's not your
nature it's not your nature to talk
about people what's that it's not your
nature to talk about people no no it's
not not my nature at all all right this
is great
one more part I understand like Joe
Rogan
what are you eating Ethan what are you
eating
a cookie oh son's a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
get the camera get the the effects in
all right here we go
[Music]
this is crazy
this whole scene in this store is you're
off the chain dude
she went into the 7-Eleven she didn't
leave till 6 10. you're a big girl
the conference calling her fat yeah it's
so wild it completely ruins the good uh
the good [ __ ] will he had with those
women it's by calling her fat
wait a second Jimmy you just asked me to
say you said that about me is it me or
her
what do you mean the cops breaking it up
both
respect
away is that what you asked yes
you gotta finish it it's not done all
right
she's a big girl what do you like
you're black and white you're all right
let me do the funny stuff where'd you
take that what's your name why do you
have your back to me what are you ready
to show I'm a black guy too I just I
didn't get enough Sun how you doing
honey you look good I want to make
passion I love you yes on a bumpy road
so we can have a bouncing baby what do
you think about that come on over here
look at that two good reason to see you
come on in Nina repeat it
she's Hawaiian she's from the island if
I like a dick
[Music]
like a big Dickie
oh my God it's getting nuts it's getting
crazy in Miami's Beach I go I go fishing
I catch something I got oranges I catch
everything I'm having a [ __ ] rough
time Daniel and you guys think it's a
big joke that I'm having problems
it's awesome anyway there's one where he
starts eating their food but uh oh you
like that one guy then yeah we got it we
got enough so where am I going where am
I going with my career South of the
Border I don't think you I don't think
your humor is uh could no I don't think
I think it's too subtle for uh Telemundo
if that's what you're asking actually
maybe you should go maybe you should go
to try and become a mogul in in
Telemundo start dressing in ladies
clothing maybe a horny you become a
horny clown there's a lot of stuff you
could do you could Branch out if you're
going to go more Vaudeville but I think
what you're doing is great Jimmy
honestly I've turned I've done a
complete 180. I think you should stay
with exactly what you're doing like I
said as an art project it's very
interesting one more clip this one ABC
yeah
two hot mamas two MILFs two MILFs
married all over them
people are scared no pull in here
so this is my grandfather Jimmy Lee we
take them out here every Tuesday look
he's off his meds and he's been drinking
so I apologize
what song are we doing
if you're having a good time let me hear
you say yay yay
this is what I'm talking about why did
they listen to him I don't know like you
have some weird Charisma
that it's just people are confused and
they listen for some reason so stop us
so we we went out with him and he
totally hijacked anything we had planned
this was supposed to be a bit where I
was like his Protege right and he was
going to show me around but you can't oh
you can't you can't keep Jimmy you can't
keep the outlaw within the law dude the
Outlaw's gonna break out listen Timmy so
I I got you this time I hope it was
helpful it was it actually really was
like
I think I learned that I'm doing what I
enjoy it's probably not going to work in
today's climate and according to your
your nice comedian friend he said stay
with it because it's fun but don't
expect an Roi and I'll stay with it
because I'm a dreamer and I like it you
got it the love you gave me and the
honesty you know and all sincerity is
appreciated and I kind of knew that
answer but to hear it from a
professional comedian validates it but
it's a hard thing for a guy like me to
let go of something I enjoy what are we
doing sure you know if you're going to
make it happen it's got to be with
yourself don't think that anyone is
gonna make it happen for you I know when
I was talking to my team this weekend
about because we don't get bounce back
from media you know people are robbing
you whatever your team is I'm aware of
that okay give me give me how many
people do you employ on your team
five five okay what are their roles
what's that videographer what do we got
editor
that's the social media people I'm not
talking about the oh this is just your
day-to-day
we're talking about day-to-day people
your manager who are we talking Steve
Rossi Zach's friend okay
he is Steve Rossi okay you know what you
mean I'm gonna end it on one wholesome
moment here okay this is from our edit
and I think you'll enjoy this uh uh oh
we met we had this big moment where you
got they were about to get out of the
limousine and here is like the kind of
the big famous quote they had they had
quote a crowd gathered they're like
someone's famous coming out so here's
Jimmy's he let the limo like stir a
little bit okay no I don't like that
here it is
this is the biggie this is the baby
the biggie
[Music]
hold it I want to check audio audio on
Dave you have my audio where's he you
have audio
I want you guys to meet my gate my gay
friend Zach
and last year I took him on a vacation
and everybody came where are you from
how come you don't eat the muffins
listen yeah see that's what's again so
beautiful right because you have this
like Unstoppable Charisma when you're
just ruining people's lunches but they
have this moment set up right now's the
time to shine and you come out bumbling
[ __ ] ask and telling everyone your
friend is gay and just
it's incredible that that's awesome that
was so good so good you're a beautiful
Paradox Jimmy you're a beautiful Paradox
Jimmy we have to say goodbye now
okay I just had one question okay go
ahead
does the Charisma and the outrageousness
count for anything to get anywhere
absolutely you kept mentioning Charisma
you gotta stop talking about the get
anywhere aspect what what do you again
in your mind's eye tell me what you what
does get anywhere mean to you well I
just want to get famous
for what does that mean to you you're on
TV you're on Netflix you get started
Jimmy Kimmel like Jimmy Kimmel on the
street you're on HD podcast yeah you're
you first of all you've made it this is
a huge show that's number one but you
have to and I appreciate it here's what
you need here's what you need
say it's Jimmy Kimmel you need one goal
and you got to figure out how do I get
there instead of this like just firing
on in all different directions well he
he was recently invited on Newsmax today
oh that's awesome
comedians can no longer do jokes or bear
get a canceled
that's awesome again that's another
beautiful another beautiful chapter in
the Jimmy in the Jimmy uh [ __ ] magnum
opus okay all right that's awesome we
gotta say goodbye I love you guys I
really appreciate it great job Jimmy
great have a good day all right you too
brother all right the whole Jimmy Lee
sagas awesome beginning to end no he
rocks he should have been in my life for
a goddamn gotta be a decade
that's awesome salute to Jimmy but I
can't tell some people they go no more
Jimmy but I love him like yeah it's like
I just can't resist no he's an
incredibly fascinating guy and yeah
you're right it's like one of a kind
Nathan feel the rest but again Fielder
is like a genius and Jimmy's the exact
opposite well he's like he's Nathan
fielders his character how other people
see his kids right right that's true
yeah each time he's Bizarro Nathan
Fielder is what it is he's it's like he
but really yeah yeah he rules so there
that is shout out to Jimmy so Jimmy Lee
yeah he nothing you told him will stick
oh without question he's already
forgotten it
already forgotten it we had like a big
intervention we tried to set him
straight five people and that's he's
like that doesn't count the social media
team that's crazy I have three people
that work I have a team of three
but also right after we did the
intervention he came out with that
little people joke what was it that you
posted on Instagram
[Laughter]
they're like really nice sweet normal
kids yeah
yeah he he kept this part of himself
bottled up until they were gone uh
there's a theory going in the office
that uh he doesn't have a team it's all
figments of his imagination that's
awesome I would love that even more but
no someone is definitely robbing him
without question no yeah there's so many
people are like oh yeah for sure so I
want to talk to you one more thing yes
we've been going for a minute now right
uh yeah we're at uh two and a half hours
nice what should we do so PornHub
revealed their popular 22 searches so we
could go over the PornHub analytics or
um I've got a bunch of videos I want to
show you just goofy kind of whatever's
in your heart I'd love to go either one
let's check out the PornHub stats so
it's always super interesting let's do
it so here let me open that up
instead how is it done it's it's like
location by location yeah so every year
they have a report based on Trends and
stuff and this one is really
comprehensive interesting
um let's see searches that Define 2022
reality
hmm no real surprises here homemade
and then we go down let's see the
position
so those those terms Hentai Hentai
number one and that's I've noticed that
one last year was also hentai came out
here [ __ ] with hentai I dabbled but
not nothing crazy you know it wasn't in
the I was either in my youth I was like
I watched a lot of Dragon Ball Z and I
was like
gotta find some of the girls well I'd
like to see Bulma suck dick you know
what I mean I'd like to see what's that
look like well you're not alone but I'm
not it's not my go-to and then the other
one is interesting is this was the same
as last year too Japanese that's got to
be a they've got to be connected right
maybe you're right I think it's Japanese
cartoon it's probably something like
that because if it was women they'd go
Asian Pinay is number five of specific
isn't that like Filipino or something
like that oh yeah you're not Asian
that's very interesting that there
appears to be a a sexual uh sexually
people are turning towards the Orient by
the way amateur models shout out to a
friend of the show morgue pie morgue pie
okay yes on top of the list good for
them let's see um most Search terms in
the United States
lesbian lesbian hentai ebony lesbian
makes sense because I think everybody
participates in that yeah search yes
that's the great sexual Venn diagram the
middle part yeah is lesbian everyone is
jacking off to that and uh actually so
let's see lesbian hentai ebony I just
don't understand people really type
ebony like isn't there better but it
seems so old school and also you should
combine Ebony and black you'd think
right people they're literally typing
ebony well because I do when we first
started beating off for whatever reason
ebony was how black porn was under the
races
that's like the car the it's like how
they have the that's what they would
name the black greeting cards at CVS
it's like the ebony section I think they
literally call like mahogany or
something no joke it's like black
greeting cards but it is weird that
ebony is like because before you've got
to be old people problem I don't know
what it is it's strange have you ever
heard of ebony Olivia I only asked you
because you're the probably the youngest
you know that
in terms of porn yeah
I mean I know it's a category
yeah I don't know much more right it's
just black people yeah yeah but when
don't you isn't that remember before you
could even search remember the days
where it was just like categories yeah
you would click around ebony was if you
wanted to jack off to a black girl you
would have to go Ebony and I think a lot
of people it's still in their brain have
you heard of that love or is that an old
person thing
so there's a lot of people still on
PornHub
um let's see so this one's super
interesting the top New York and New
York the New York is Dominican that's
awesome so let's see in Pennsylvania uh
California is Asian now this one was the
weirdest one in Alaska that's the
expansion I had no idea what does that
even mean like fake I did some research
okay it's a hentai where they have like
their tits are like 20 sizes you know
what that is expand you know what that
is it's Alaska it's one guy beating off
to that so much that he's throwing off
the whole numbers
not a lot of people there there's one
guy who's juicing the stats for sure
when I looked up expanding uh breasts it
wasn't very high viewed videos like the
most had fifty thousand so you might be
right yeah I think it's that one guy
what's going on where's that Michigan
so on PornHub apparently ebony is still
its own category that's weird it's weird
that sounds less racist black
but you know there's a website right now
that's very popular called black today
oh maybe maybe black is if you want
black [ __ ] it's blacked slash black
ebony if you want black [ __ ] oh I think
that's probably how I actually cracked
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm an ebony guy what can I say I prefer
now Florida they're loving big black
hawk which is interesting in a very
conservative you know white today
BBC is that furries out in uh Oregon or
Washington Oregon oh yeah this is good
this is like do I know my [ __ ] do I
know my stage the Mormons in Utah I love
that they can't they can't they're even
jacking off of themselves [ __ ] losers
dude shower what is that [ __ ] like
living dirt yeah imagine a girl in the
shower boy or is that Nevada what's is
that no that's Nevada that's Nevada what
the [ __ ] is that Utah this has got to be
is that Arizona
right what's the one next out here in
Arizona we imagine oh I'd like to see a
girl
goth who's God
Colorado is in the goth [ __ ]
interesting big booty out here the great
state of Wyoming Wyoming leather Montana
lots of cows maybe oh yellow Yellowstone
that's how you look up Heather maybe
that's how you look up cow porn
I don't know what they do up there I
love um I love sucking dick that's right
oh this one uh the great state of
Wisconsin right no Michigan dude
the Wisconsin is in the package
and Michigan's in the sucking dip which
is frankly a very generic search I agree
that fits a lot of categories what's
Maryland I'm from Baltimore ASMR people
people are jacking off to being like
pull your penis out
is
the ASMR is a phenomenal so they close
their eyes and jack off like like a
lady's whispering to them
I think they want I think their eyes are
open their eyes are open yeah okay
interesting
smoking I'm not a big ASMR guy gelf oh
wow let's go let's get right past
Tennessee straight strap-on wow wow what
state is gilf gilf Grandma
South Carolina yeah they skipped the
MILF they said this is ice cream like
like a genteel old southern lady why
don't you come on in here play with Mom
let me hit let me hit them and then
North Carolina's big black ass
yeah but I think I think my favorite
here is um Florida being all for the big
black [ __ ] right right oh is that which
BBW Mississippi or Arkansas is that one
of those this would be everyone's fat as
[ __ ] Alabama yeah it makes a lot of
sense that's like Utah uh jacking off
the Mormon he's just Alabama jacking off
the BBW
uh let's see
countries by traffic this was not
interesting obviously America it's
American website
spent time versus visit so this is
basically how long does it take each
country to bust female vision is six
seconds more interesting so when and
that that's actually kind of comforting
because you always hear it takes women
longer right there's really just a six
second right right right right
it's on
[Laughter]
time spent per visit per state so wow
Alabama for whatever reason is uh takes
their time what was the is that the big
it's interesting it's all the South it's
like everything everything moves slower
in the South yeah yeah you take your
time slow lock my life yeah yeah yeah I
drip off slow like my life maybe they're
having trouble with the computers
they have poor infrastructure
possible
Ohio they bust fast yeah and then you
well yeah Ohio they get it done they're
busy you know we love that for them
yeah thank you Jake Paul time so this is
also real interesting when do we watch
porn
yeah 5am is crazy there's some real
psycho hours here like yeah I'm on
cocaine I'm on 5am is like I'm on
cocaine I've been beating off for three
and a half hours I started beating off
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna look up a [ __ ] up video
because nothing else this one's really
crazy noon
just beating your meat at me honestly I
have done that a couple times if you if
you if you need to reset well you're
you're a comedian that's true I don't
have a regular life that's true that's
true but being like a normal ass working
dude you can't beat your meat at 2PM I
don't know how about this if you have a
lot of work to do and you're horny and
you know there's no time to [ __ ] yeah
instead of letting that evil marinate in
your balls all day the poison and make
you think about getting [ __ ] get it out
at lunch and then have a very productive
one to five p.m you know I'm for it I
think that maybe apple and Microsoft you
know how they're very Progressive with
the word first I think they need a jerk
off brick they absolutely do by the way
this could be pandemic related because
everyone's working at home because I
don't see any reason how everyone be
jerking off between one and like four
because you're working then that's true
that's true but so you're also trying to
like you know you're also trying to make
the day go by
you know so you just beat off beat off
of four by the time you're out it's 4
15. you [ __ ] you work for 10 more
minutes and then
35 minutes to go the countdown yeah I
would take a when I had a office job I
would take a real long [ __ ] around 4pm
and what a real long like [ __ ] huh a
what shop when I I just said when I had
an office job oh an office job what did
you do in the office I was a paralegal
for a while really before that was my
last job yeah yeah that's not a bad job
is it it was bad because I worked for a
[ __ ] I worked for a foreclosure law
firm during the housing crisis and once
I figured out that that's what it did I
just didn't do any work because I was
like I don't want to be a part of this
man honestly yeah and I thought I'd get
fired for in a month and they didn't
fire me for like eight months that's
awesome so I was just doing I was just
figuring out what you did though right
it wasn't bad at the time yeah I mean
this was like this is like 10 years ago
at this point yeah um it was before I
moved to New York and so I just wanted
to stack up money and then yeah I didn't
have I wasn't gonna do the work so I was
like I'm [ __ ] for an hour I'll get like
Robin Hood dude
you're like lazy yeah office space yeah
I was an open Miker yeah you know I was
just getting good at commenting it's a
nice time in my life so this is the most
popular we got Monday at 11 p.m that
makes sense this makes sense to me so if
you if you find yourself masturbating at
11 PM just know you're sure you're in
good company no you're sheep start
beating off yeah that's true start being
off at 11AM no yo go against the grave 5
a.m on a Tuesday set an alarm wake up
jack off go to sleep yo y'all need to be
beating off at 9am Sunday morning
literally you'd be the only one meet the
presses on you're jacking off
all right so most viewed categories
lesbian oh we already talked about why
they showing the same [ __ ] over again
this is interesting uh world's most
viewed categories by country Russia's
Russian China is Japanese
that's it wait what yeah the whole the
Chinese want to [ __ ] the Japanese I
guess that's the the cultural hegemony
of the Japanese
which I I could be wrong but I don't
think uh it's legal to make porn in
China so they they have to rely oh
that's the colors
what about Korean though you know they
got nothing just straight straight to
just I think the whole everything the
whole Peninsula but you'd think with all
the K-pop [ __ ] people want to jack off
the Korean people because they're the
fan that's what I would think too but
maybe that's where
I see lots of like Asian I don't know if
that factors in but America's lesbian
God Bless America that's uh Canada right
America right I don't know what happened
there I thought all of North America
trans respect wait all of America got
ebony I guess overall it's the biggest
one okay yeah Brazil was the only
country where their top search was
transgender so shut up Brazil shout out
to LBC LBGTQ uh Heroes
Austria Russia's Russian that's awesome
is this Egypt what's this damn
everyone's ass [ __ ] over there that's
not Egypt Egypt's on the other side
isn't it or what the [ __ ] is this
country I don't know you sure oh this is
Egypt no
no Egypt is
yeah that's Saudi Arabia oh anal I
wonder if they do like a Mormon thing
where they if they have sex in the ass
it's they don't lose their virginity uh
yeah or they [ __ ] is that a thing maybe
I think I I don't know how true it is
but I have heard of that and after Saudi
Arabia but from other countries
don't they all right I don't want to
yeah they also do some other condos they
also [ __ ] other people in the ass I
think go on
um
children
do you think there's like a Saudi Arabia
there's like a you're [ __ ] I think
there's like a weird uh almost ancient
an ancient Greek style yeah relationship
between like a mentor and a guy who
[ __ ] have you heard that I've never
heard that one I think so no not me
did that ever happen UAB nope you're the
closest thing I have to a mentor you
haven't tried yet have you you ever
[ __ ] his ass yet well son
I still have a lot left to teach you
uh reality let's see top gaining
categories the reality was popular now
this one is I like this one it's
interesting 160 coming up Big Time
Babysitting feels outdated that's the
fact that's up 150 seems weird to me a
return a return to tradition yeah return
to Reagan's America
maybe once yeah but scattering I find
that interesting I thought that was like
a joke I don't think a lot of I didn't
think lesbian scissor that much I
thought it was like a a fun move you
sprinkle in but it's not the bread and
butter
right it does a 69 it's like exactly
it's like it's fun to but it's not
really right but I don't know I think
scissoring could be the whole main I
don't think so we got Intel on this I
don't remember what it was for but no
you know yeah someone said that it's
because
uh lesbians like to watch it because
it's real when they're watching a guy a
lot of times scissoring seems like a
fake sex act to me like I could see it
though you know what I mean uh because
like sometimes a girl just really I feel
like I've had sexual encounters where
the best part for the woman was when she
was like weirdly rubbing her [ __ ] on my
leg Yeah so if you do if you just double
up the [ __ ] if you go [ __ ] on [ __ ]
I know what you're talking kind of like
our friend uh what was his name the
prolapse King hunger yeah hunger Hunger
FF the way they went [ __ ] inside of
[ __ ] or inside of [ __ ] going push
you to [ __ ] that kind of style dude I
think scissoring's dope it's just like
um it's like it's like what you imagine
lesbian sex
as someone who's like has no idea how
the world works but apparently they do
scissor I think they do but I feel like
Timbers I think I think if we looked at
how much time is spent scissoring it's a
it's way lower to finger popping and
[ __ ] eating without question well
there's actually I think there's more
stats I think let's get more stats of
the lesbian categories well here let's
we'll get to it okay so matured people
or taking the longest to bust that makes
a lot of sense prostate's acting up you
know what I mean waiting for you yeah
yeah
yeah
um oh so these are the fastest muscular
men gay guys
uncentered cartoon of course there's the
bus quick scissoring is very hot
scissoring viewed short is because it's
not real that's like a little that's a
little appetizer to get the [ __ ] eaten
you move on to you move on yeah okay big
tits redhead those are kind of two of my
faves so here's most searched gay terms
hentai Stills twink everybody loves it
Hanoi for gay guys too what's what's
going on yeah
but Twinkies great that's interesting
see you'll notice no ebony here
that's so interesting you really cracked
the code man I'm pretty proud of that
one top trending gay searches big dick
is crushing at everything Horse the
[ __ ] the Chicago Bulls of the 90s of
gay Search terms
you can't beat big dick F to M being
200.
female to male like trans stuff yeah
yeah yeah someone who born a born woman
goes man okay interesting gay guys are
jacking off to that respect I love that
for you cruising I guess respect home
what is cruising cruising is uh well I
didn't know say I watched the movie
cruising it's a gay term for just going
out and looking at a guy and maybe
sucking his [ __ ] off a glare alone I
believe okay so you're cruising for a
day you're cruising for addiction I'll
take whatever comes whatever comes my
way
yeah okay that's interesting I believe
so I don't know no that sounds right
yeah that sounds right
most viewed uh gay category so this
one's super interesting this gave me
James Charles the gay guys loved the
straight guy fantasy wow James Charles
[ __ ] straight guys well he got into all
kinds of trouble because he was just
trying to like
he was like harassing straight man
basically basically a borderline
borderline raping straight man Jesus
Christ yeah and kids by the way oh
that's no that's no good very young now
we understand now we've taken the fun
out of it I was gonna do a whole riff
about about that but I'll pass yeah no
it wasn't funny but black is number two
group twink daddy there we go big dick
is kind of slipping right
that's well I think the difference
between a search and a category right
isn't that how I uh he was not accused
of of rape
uh uh I said you know borderline I said
borderline I'm good I'm good onto the
borderline yeah yeah you don't want to
get you want to get you know shoot for
slander oh absolutely I mean I don't
think you could slander James Charles
but you don't want yeah let's not take
any risks
uh so we got let's see Japanese
[ __ ] reality they're not really into
the [ __ ] and [ __ ] shots the gays
there so interesting so those are two
pretty cool things as far as I'm
concerned it's hot so I don't know who
this guy is Dante Cole is crushing you
must have a nice piece dude what's going
on with Dante because it can't just be
nice penis he's got to be doing
something else he's got to be a good
marketer he's crushing it I don't know
can we see Dante Cole's penis well well
if you take it off the screen we can do
it do you know who that is Olivia are
you did
no but I just pulled a photo of it so
here's oh this is safe for work you can
show this so this is our boy
right there I'm not seeing anything that
I mean he look he looks great yeah he's
fit but he might be talented he might
suck a dick like nobody's business some
people in the chat seem that they seem
familiar with Dante what are they what's
his strength yeah what makes it Dante
the goat uh what sets him apart Dante it
says suffer in silence
so he doesn't even moan when you [ __ ]
his ass that doesn't sound he's a great
receiver
[Laughter]
details but definitely definitely some
more yeah but I mean this guy is
dominating the category so it's super
interesting I'm literally about to click
on one of his videos to answer your
questions
going above and beyond yeah but you know
if you're comfortable with that I mean
it's just it's
regular stuff
don't show the video but show the uh
play the audio
there's a lot way there's a lot of
opinions lawyer okay oh he's been he's
called The Destroyer so he's got it's
just a a title that somebody gave him in
the chat just now so he must have a nice
um his videos are behind
further research go ahead baby it
doesn't I'm surprised at what I'm seeing
I mean I haven't watched a video but
some photos doesn't seem like he's
packing that much well maybe he sucks
dick good maybe he's just hot yeah but
he's not he's fine he's passionate Lover
he must just be a good marketer he's
really nice
he's just a cool guy this is sweet bro
we need to be considered he's okay
his penis is not like super big is it
nice it looks very does it look nice
like average looks average wow let me
see let me see what you guys think yeah
this I got to see I'm already pissed off
I think you're lying send me a picture
in Discord and take it off screen please
I'm going to see this man's dick
and markiplier I'm looking at you next
you [ __ ] coward all right I'm sending
you a link don't open it I mean don't
don't show it all right yeah we good uh
this is this is Flushing oh well that's
flaccid let me see it I can't really
tell flaccid I mean yeah you can get a
sense though right I mean that's not a
bit I think that thing could be real big
hard it's flasted I need a hard is that
fully flashed or is that 45 wait what's
with his leg oh true hey what the [ __ ]
is he here you got that [ __ ]
Targaryen wait what no oh he's got has
he got like been doing he's got some
kind of I bet you that's a pretty nice
penis hard uh let's not get at it let's
not get crazy yeah how dare you guys
despair just don't think oh you all need
to send me a boner pic
okay we're trying to do journalism here
yeah he must have been doing a Chimney
Sweeper
I'm sorry I left me chimney sweeps
this ass out upside down oh
that's so true yeah so um anyway that is
shout out donkey I found his hard dick
nice how's it looking it looks like the
most average really okay the beginning
so that's kind of it's not about the
size for a lot of people you know that's
encouraging I like that you know I think
it's bigger than average the soft disc
looked pretty big I can't these websites
have so much spam like frankly I think
it's discriminatory how much
homophobic you think yeah
okay oh my God what did you just send me
what did you send Olivia here I got it I
got it okay here it is this is better
okay went through a lot of here it is oh
you're right that is average I guess
that's not that crazy of a dick that's a
totally average I mean it's nice but
average yeah
maybe a hair above average
maybe just a little above average
uh so there it is a really nice guy I
bet he's a good guy but I bet he's got
he's got a nice marketing like apparatus
behind them what's the equivalent like
crowd work clips and stand up that that
does the algorithm for us what's the gay
porn algorithm equivalent
you know sucking off can't say anything
I had a I had a premonition of people
getting mad at me okay good
I'm working on that all right nice Chris
Fabio okay so this one's real
interesting men consumption versus women
consumption most viewed categories by
when so this how interesting is this
lesbian is by far the biggest category
for women so men and women unite to make
the lesbian category right all powerful
right well lesbian is pretty
it's low on them you know let's say low
but you're right but men again we're
hitting the Japanese like both the
Japanese I don't know what do they look
I now suspect because we saw that
worldwide one that China alone there's
so many people there I think that that
probably skews it heavily in that
direction wow okay so wait let me oh I
didn't need all that
let me read the paragraph Community who
says Google analytics yeah billions of
visits so yeah you're right this is
China I wonder if they yeah let's see do
they have just America I'd be they they
do
but yeah most viewed by women compared
to men number one by Mark Fitzgerald the
winner love scissors solo mail a lot of
jacking oh interesting guys jacking off
[ __ ] licking I love that that's an
awesome thing to put into a search bar I
frankly love the women's cert I think
they're really have a good taste for
bisexual male interesting they want to
see a guy get [ __ ] and then also [ __ ]
them
uh porn star by women whatever
women also love Dante Cole wow uh female
visitors uh
uh whatever the Philippines wow the
Philippines they're more Filipino
Filipinos are beating off more the women
more than men which actually is the and
Colombia Mexico is almost 50 but if you
got into America for example only 30
percent 29 shame that's a real shame you
know what I mean like we got to get
those numbers up big difference gals
start beating off the pornography now
but that's also pornography versus
how what are the regular jacking off
numbers
are ladies just jacking off I think they
have access to this stuff
I'd love to see those this one's a
little disturbing because women can jack
off like nice memories yeah you know
what I mean like like a good trip they
took with with a boyfriend you know
right right men need to see someone yeah
dude the way you stroke the prolapse
really is gonna stick with me him being
like I'm lovingly chugging it like it's
a [ __ ] when they struggling I knew
that was I had seen it all that was
[ __ ] brutal yeah but uh shut up
though he's a talent he's a good time I
mean talented guy
yeah this one's a little disturbing 18
to 24 is the biggest category and you
know those kids are all under 18 too
like a lot of them really oh I mean they
gotta be I mean you know there's a lot
of kids under 18. how do they know this
yeah I don't I don't log into that [ __ ]
who logged in
like them to know that these are people
with accounts maybe they have tracking
cookies that changes everything if it
you need an account for these yeah this
doesn't count at all the other ones you
could you could figure out just by like
the the yeah stats coming in but the age
thing I don't know they said it's from
Google Analytics so it's based on like
their Gmail and [ __ ] but like anonymized
okay okay
well there you go
yeah
I uh I wonder I wonder if young people
are jacking off the PornHub that seems
almost old-fashioned I wonder if there's
like a like some weird VR dick suck
there's some weird way we don't even
know about the kids are beating off that
would be I bet you kids don't use
PornHub as much either because it's also
like the official one it's a boomer app
it's like Facebook
are beating off you know what I learned
what's that women love fan fiction
um true like
and God bless him for that you know yeah
I we read one the other day on the show
about the Mandalorian get jerked off I
was like did he still keep the thing on
the yeah he kept the helmet on damn
actually no they [ __ ] in the pitch
black darkness oh so he didn't take it
off and so he took the helmet off that's
awesome good for him wow in that story
Wattpad gen Z loves threesomes oh look
at them cosplay cartoons they're
cosplaying cartoons vertical video
that's what I'm saying they jack off
like it's tick tocks
oh I get it if you're holding your phone
maybe it's a better nah [ __ ] that dude
these [ __ ] kids need to learn how to
beat all [ __ ] landscape
no son of mine is beating off vertical
aspect ratio of your of your porn well
if I had to guess because it's similar
to like Snapchat and the types of home
videos that they've seen or made
themselves I guess yeah still just going
out of your way to search for this but
that's what I mean there's got to be a
there's got to be a website that will
cater to that soon that's all that's
literally Tick Tock but people are
sucking dicks for real that's definitely
happening where is that I bet you it's
out now it's in beta Brian Kavanaugh
I've been gift for you
he's uh he's my arch nemesis but won't
get anything nice okay Gen Y loves
Asians okay Gen X loves cream pies Gen Y
they're more that's more because I think
they're more into having babies
[Laughter]
the good day cream pie not being
divorced yo this one [ __ ] cracked me
up the Boomers
[Laughter]
respect they can't imagine anything no
spicier than that well dude the thing is
if you're that old your dick probably
doesn't work that good so you just want
to get a nice jack off and then go back
to watching like Jeopardy or whatever
you just want to get beaten off after
your TV dinner and then you can see who
wins Wheel of Fortune well you also love
pissing pissing interesting
and vintage everything
vintage the good old days boy yeah
um huh Everyone's Watching on their
phones I know when I want to treat
myself I break out the laptop when I
play I like the most shop it's so much
nicer that's yeah yeah just whatever
desktop laptop sitting down on a
computer but it's all phone man
everyone's being off to the phone I get
it Android Apple 50 50 50 15.
um
web browser come on you guys I didn't
need all this
game game console people are beating up
on PlayStation
I never thought to do that
that's crazy
73 of all PS Vista [ __ ] is that the
little handheld thing
so they even make PS Vistas anymore what
the [ __ ] well it's actually down it was
popular last year they must have a great
app that's what it is here's a movie
parodies and characters Harley Quinn
crushing it it makes sense Star Wars
What's 365 days what the [ __ ] is that
they stopped making Vistas in 2015. what
they're dude shout out to the Vista they
must have a they must offer an
incredible jacking off experience if
people are seven years later they still
crack even one percent good for them
that's someone's preferred method
it's the same guy with breast and large
it's the one guy in Alaska he's watching
expanding breasts on a Vista I just
can't get off do anything but my Vista
Princess Leia with the staying power not
Vista oh Vita Alaska
smaller one yeah who hasn't beat off to
Elastigirl and I'm not talking about
PornHub I'm talking about who's Alexa oh
The Incredibles the his wife oh true fat
ass probably can shrink her [ __ ] with
her elastic Powers bro yeah that's
awesome respect to her
The Joker is coming in last but he's
still there fortnite that's kind of
weird that that's a child's game that's
[ __ ] up well that's kids trying to
jack off to what they play video games
with OverWatch Minecraft there's crazy
Minecraft Pokemon
um throw Misty in there Minecraft box
Misty huh so most searched video game
character we had a really interesting
Journey on this OverWatch Diva I get but
then the second one was Minecraft Jenny
mom who that is
can you guys send me a picture there's
Minecraft Jenny so this was a mod on
Minecraft that apparently kids were
choosing to get off but it's just
pixelated [ __ ] Minecraft that's
awesome it's just a block lady let's see
her it's it's literally what you it's
it's just here I swear to God we can
show this yeah check it out
oh hell yeah I'm in yeah
I love how it's all blocky but our
titties yeah
we updated the uh I mean yeah I get it
okay I get it Minecraft
holidays like as especially if I was a
kid I would absolutely be jacking off
the Minecraft Journey right I guess so I
guess so it's a Gateway World Cup
traffic I will say during the Olympics I
definitely put rugby girl into the okay
PornHub search bar right I was watching
women's rugby and I was like hold on a
second so all right
USA Top terms so hentai's still up there
but Japanese see the difference you're
right I think China has really thrown
those Japanese numbers okay but hentai
hentai though still up there damn that's
such a that's a huge Market it really is
good for them animators finally getting
paid yeah
yeah trans [ __ ] girl thick Latina
reverse cuckold hold on what huh revert
oh is that one that's what it says when
the husband gets [ __ ] by the dude I
don't know no I think that's just when
the wife watches
the dude another girl though oh oh
interesting
uh wait so so reverse shout out to Jenny
the girls wait wait the guys have just I
imagine there's two guys having sex
that's not happening a guy the girl
watches yeah no I mean if it's just
inverse then yeah
I mean that sounds pretty cool a girl
watch me for a girl I don't wanna I
don't want to [ __ ] a man's wife while
the guy's in there I have no interest in
that someone at home is jerking off to
this right now yeah no when I yeah it's
it's a wife watching her husband have
sex with another woman
I'm interested in that that's a good cat
I didn't know that was right or anyone
but yeah the top results are all other
women
good time it's very interesting the UK
let's do it deprived [ __ ] there into
MILFs I like a good old I can't do that
yeah kind of similar though
MILF lesbian hentai through Indian yeah
see that
kind of the same you ever you watch rrr
Pro says hey what's our RR it's uh it's
an Indian movie where the British are
probably Nazis it is it is the most
amazing movie ever that movie
oh it's on Netflix yeah like three and a
half hours long it's incredible dude
the English are Nazi they're basically
they're they're not cheap yeah yeah like
the English are real high and mighty
about taking down Nazis and [ __ ] but you
were the original a bunch of people's
Nazis and you got away with it and I
mean Hitler based this whole shtick off
of how we treated black or I mean we I
wouldn't even [ __ ] hear yeah it was
my family yeah okay
yeah yeah my family was in Greece until
the 80s Let's go people had Jerry curls
when we came here I had nothing to do
with slavery I didn't benefit well
probably yeah that's for sure
uh France hentai is everywhere
lesbians it's crazy that being Khalifa
are still on that list when she hasn't
made anything in years I know yeah he's
like Rihanna but she's on a list yeah I
think she's not only fans but it
wouldn't have the content on the only
fans to check it out I haven't seen him
I'd be interested I was a fan I was
swept up in Khalifa fever when she came
out which is still like number one is
that crazy
congratulations congrats to her she's
got staying power
Japan uh oh the Japanese watch it's
gonna be like American yeah
Japanese
yeah dude well they they're pretty
they're they're an ethno state for sure
they're racist to everyone but the
Japanese but they're really nice about
their racism right but they are right
they make it nice and palatable they
smile to you at you but it's like if
you're not Japanese you pay more in rent
than a Japanese person but they're like
oh and we try I was visiting Japan we
tried like going to a building they're
like No And I was like why they're like
just no no just Japanese and they're
smiling they're not like you know no no
yeah I'm like all right I guess yeah
they are nice about it Brazil here we go
so Adam everyone's got hentai yeah Spain
hentai Jesus Poland do we have grease on
here it's probably too small a country
Netherlands there we go Turkish wow they
don't have hentai anywhere
but still
that's a that's an indicator and some
some's up with that
um Ukraine damn they got time to beat
off
don't you [ __ ] got [ __ ] to be
doing
Putin's coming just put your [ __ ]
dick away oh I'll tell you who's jerking
off at uh you know at 12 on a Sunday
afternoon
in the Foxhole
all right I don't I don't know it's not
that simple is Greece is Greece anywhere
I would love to let me see my countrymen
but I don't think so let me guess hentai
though
come on come on [ __ ] no that's a that's
a bummer
that's a real shame so there it is we
learned a little bit we learned I love
learning and that's important I love to
learn
oh here we have Greece
it's on a separate page ah let's check
it out let's see what my countrymen are
jacking off the grease inside I love
that they did US gave us a little extra
wait uh maybe maybe don't show it just
to be sure
these are usually clean you know usually
oh this is from 2017.
oh well this is old data
jerking off for 10 minutes 21 female
50 mobile this is so old though you know
it's not even
that's yeah they love the Greek
celebrity Greek porn Greek amateur
Nicole which means Greek lesbian
Athens step foot job
but see I was really interested to see
it in a in a new one if they're jacking
off the hentai I don't think it might be
I don't think it's made it to Greece yet
they everybody we're behind bro truly
culturally we're behind a lot of stuff
all right all right yeah but I'd like to
see it well there it is
um that's good stuff we've been through
a lot yeah an
odyssey yeah we've seen it all I think
that's about it yeah I mean Jimmy Lee
he's never gonna change no he's great we
loved him and uh and we learned a lot
shout out to Jimmy Lee thanks for the
cookies of course dude and guys just a
reminder
you can get tickets you can tour links
in the description
www.stabby with two v's two v's in a y
stavi dot Biz we got [ __ ] calendars
for sale we got [ __ ]
you know go buy these uh and then the
podcast stop this world on YouTube yeah
guys check it out come check it out if
you haven't seen a special it's on his
YouTube watch the special subscribe to
everything I got a family to feed
I don't I'm a single man but well one
day family
me too
that's a good one yeah
all right guys thanks for watching it is
is it from what's today it's Wednesday
Thursday we got leftovers with the song
tomorrow morning oh [ __ ] him [ __ ] that
guy yeah real piece of [ __ ]
are you a radical Lefty by the way I
yeah I would say so I'm a lefty for sure
your Association I'm in there he's
always right huh
oh yeah not eating and not eating on the
podcast yeah yeah I think everyone's
getting [ __ ] in the ass in America and
we should just take a little money from
the [ __ ] going to the Moon
instead of people dying because they
know you answer I love one of your jokes
on your special you said we should
oh yeah yeah don't say that yeah
assassinate can I say that
I've done twice for similar jokes
literally bam I was like this is my guy
yeah yeah yeah
that was a funny video thank you thank
you thank you thank you
yeah yeah we should no we don't we don't
wish everybody everyone does well but
hey pay your employees a living wage you
know maybe you're going over your
shoulder you're going to the [ __ ]
Moon let a [ __ ] guy take a piss
without a stopwatch going off on the
Amazon floor indeed Jeff Bezos and um
what's his name Captain Kirk
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah and did you
see what he said afterwards how
depressing it was for him I just thought
it was awesome it was awesome well when
they landed back on Earth
did you see that video chat was trying
to have like a deep moment and Jeff
Bezos is like
ruining his moment of course have you
seen it I haven't seen the video I saw I
saw Shatner's uh trailed up real thing
which was like harrowing he was so sad
that he went to his face was awesome
goodness
oh my God
[Laughter]
I can't believe
that I can't believe this oh wow yeah oh
so this is right when they land there's
a camera and they're like Shatner so how
was it and Jeff is like he's such a
[ __ ] weirdo dude yeah dude
why is he looking at him like that
okay
[Music]
come here I want one I want mine I'm
Jeff Bezos the impression I had I mean
and you Shatner literally said like he
he was so it was like horrible it's so
cool
it was crazy yeah
[Music]
I want one okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey shut the [ __ ] up oh by the way
chapters are recovering alcoholic
awesome and so he goes
look at Shatner he's just so gutted just
a [ __ ] nerd basis is just bad I want
to hear this oh yeah of course he's
associated
doing a little man
recovering alcohol out right there
stinks Shannon is so pissed
Shannon wants to see he wants to [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of him
and Jeff literally forgot about him yeah
yeah he's there like Bezos is smart
because if he he put people in the
spaceship like he put Shatner he put
like Michael Strahan he put like
teachers because he knew if it was just
him everyone would pray for it to
explode liking you he was keeping like
Karma William shatters there just to
because people love him and he wants to
deflect wishes of death he's like a
human shield he's really that's all he's
there for is to give him clout hell yes
yeah that was really sad Jeff really is
a [ __ ] animal yeah
just I really understand why these
[ __ ] don't just pay they would
be heroes if they just paid like how
much that really gonna cost you nothing
a number a number on a screen would go
down he'll it'll never change his life
whatsoever it's [ __ ] insane
so anyway [ __ ] Jeff Bezos yeah
[Laughter]
love it guys check them out super fun
hell yeah
good luck man we'll be following thank
you brother yeah absolutely God bless
thanks everyone for watching seeing
tomorrow morning and on Friday's The Big
Show the sound bike Olympics we'll see
you then everyone's very excited for the
soundbike Olympics
thank you thank you peace and love
see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]